Oh gosh, I do not hide.
Oh gosh, I'll hate you.
Hey, thank you!
Welcome back to GhostTree!
My guitar is a Nexter, the Five Kipling these are my final
characters.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello,
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, Hello,
hello, hello, hello, hello.
My voice is kind of icky today.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe I've been talking too much recently.
I'm so excited to finish the game.
Yippee!
Yo, Zaki, thanks for the tag gifted.
Star Creator, thanks for the tag gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Not great for a VA heavy game.
That's okay.
I think we'll, uh...
I think we'll persevere.
I think so.
Um, what else?
What was I gonna say?
Mmm...
I don't remember.
I think, uh...
Oh!
I was messing around with some stuff.
You might notice some differences.
Hmm.
Maybe they're not so obvious, though.
Maybe.
Spenkenheim!
Thanks for that order!
Gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you.
I think my voice is all wacky because I haven't really
spoken today.
Oh yeah, hold on.
I'm quite unobservant.
That's okay.
And the gamer with OBS or...
No.
With me!
Did you cut your hair?
No.
It's still so flowy.
Yeah.
Did you get a new haircut?
No.
You're extra cute today.
You're higher up.
Oh, am I too high?
Let me.
There we go.
Does Amir is meant extra cute today?
Okay.
Why both of you saying that?
Was this an orchestrated effort?
I don't appreciate it.
I don't appreciate this.
But what I do appreciate is beating the game!
Woohoo!
Yeah!
Let's get right into it.
We have...
Hold on.
I'm just gonna go to chat.
just like because I don't remember.
We're on chapter 15.
15, 16, 17.
We have four chapters left.
And then we'll beat the game.
Yippee!
And I'm excited because last night, it ended on like a crazy
info dump cliffhanger, everything, everything.
So Mint is extra cute today.
Word on the stream.
Minto is cute today.
I I told you to cut it out!
Huh?
Anyway.
Any, anyway, anyway.
Thank you, thank you!
I completed making the homemade Memphis-style barbecue sauce
for my barbecue pulled pork complete with a side of homemade
slaw.
How are you?
How are you so competent?
I don't understand!
Minto, kawaii.
I'm overwhelmed by how cute Minto said I can't handle it.
I can't handle you!
I can't handle this.
Okay, so...
So...
Um...
Recap.
We...
Okay, recap, recap.
Um, a lot happened.
Um, we found out that the daughter that was kidnapped was
not the minister's daughter.
Instead, it was Detective Jowd's daughter.
Uh, Camilla is Detective Jowd's daughter and that she built
a contraption that is eerily similar to the one in that
pigeon guy's junkyard basement.
And, uh, the same one that killed...
in before and blue guy voice.
Oh, cutie.
No, I don't want to be him.
I don't want to hear his voice.
And stop super chatting.
How, what do you think about me?
Stop it.
Um, yeah, we hate that guy now.
We hate Shaggy now.
Um.
Um, because uh, Then we were told to get the music box
because the music box has the gun in it.
We get the music box and we figure out that the other guy
died because Missile...
Oh, Missile, Missile died.
But Missile now has powers!
Missile has special powers because of some sort of
meteorite, maybe?
Some strange meteorite fell in the park and...
that was holding Lin hostage?
Oh.
Um.
And yeah.
This will better.
This will better survive this or I'm going to riot.
So continue.
But yeah.
I believe that's everything that happened.
Anime nonsense.
Got it.
Yeah.
The Temsik.
The Temsik fell in the park and...
became Temsik Park.
And that's why the guy was trying to not have people build
in the park.
So Sara fell asleep before the last two streams, so I'm
forcing myself to stay awake.
No!
Don't force yourself!
Terushin!
No!
I have a... I plan on having a EU-friendly stream at the end
of this week, on Friday.
So, um...
You can watch that!
Mmm.
She's our Kami-oshi ghost from an inn.
Thank you.
But yeah.
The meteorite fell 10 years ago, though.
Which is still weird.
Why is that weird?
Are meteorites on a timeline?
Are they on a deadline?
But yeah.
Oh yeah, and apparently that's the biggest thing.
You're right.
Apparently Cicel was the kidnapper.
in the park 10 years ago.
Which makes no sense.
There's so much that we have to learn about.
So let's...
Let's get to it!
Let's just jump right into it.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited to beat the game.
255 a.m.
I would be passed out at this point.
That was a really wild twist.
10 years ago, a man named Sissel took a little girl named
Lynn hostage and then was killed by a meteor right fragment.
But, didn't Detective Jout say that the guy's name was not
Cicil?
Thank you for yapping.
I got stuck in traffic.
I almost didn't make it, so I'm hyped.
Let's go Saku!
Welcome home!
O'Kairi, nasaimasei!
Niels, thank you for the prank!
No, no one has said that today.
I don't think anybody will say it today.
Anyway.
And then we're was killed by a meteorite fragment mint
fragment I I killed a man tonight a man named Cecil met a
detective named Lynn at a junkyard on the edge of town and
then was killed by a bullet oh one other thing I forgot to
mention we forgot the the manipulator there's like some
other ghost man that is a manipulator it's not like a twin
situation is it like that'd be crazy cooper thanks for the
10 gifted thank you and um yeah he oh uh low battery hold on
let me uh uh oh shoot i have a cord i'm sorry
i got it okay my controller is plugged in Uh, what was I
saying?
What?
What's wrong?
Why are you guys doing the Tehapero?
Nice say it.
What do you mean, liquid?
Oh, liquid and solid sizzle?
I hope so.
Here's to our Oshi's missile.
And Minto, too.
Thank you.
Oh, my oh, she is also Missal.
Yeah.
Okay.
Tonight, a man named Sisal met a detective named Lynn at a
junkyard on the edge of town and then was killed by a
bullet.
And we think that maybe the manipulator, well, we don't
think.
We think that the manipulator manipulated the gun to kill
the mom instead of the contraption working as it was
supposed to.
that maybe we think that the manipulator possessed Lynn to
shoot Cicel.
Mezzo!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
And Smash Boo!
Why are you guys gifting so many gifted memberships today?
Why is going on?
But the scene I was waiting for me on the other end of the
phone line feels like the final nail in the coffin of my
lost memory.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, and that's right!
What is going on?
You're a suit.
Huh?
Wait.
What?
YouTube chat.
Sorry, people are talking about how cute Mincus is.
Some people say that she is extra cute today.
Well, others say that she is always cute.
I hate this.
Wait.
I see myself.
Cicilification, maybe.
What is going on?
Guffle thinks you're the gifted.
Primax thinks you're the gifted.
Niels thinks you're the tech gifted.
C2, thanks for the five gifted.
Oh my gosh.
This is the peak.
Oh, wait.
Okay, wait.
Also, because...
Detective Carbonara also betrayed us.
He said the...
You gotta kill Detective Jowd or something.
By tonight, he said the deal still stands.
He betrayed us, I think.
What is going on?
Who are you?
Liquid!
Huh?
Oh.
There you are, Commander Sith.
Huh?
Cicel.
What?
Where have you been, my good man?
We've been looking everywhere for you.
What?
Had a little unfinished business to take care of.
Didn't think it would take this long.
What about your people?
They sure went out of their way to mess me up.
How are there three of us?
Thanks for playing through one of my favorite games.
It's the first time I watched a streamer play through an
entire game from start to finish.
It's been kind of poggers.
I hope you enjoy the finale.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I believe we fulfilled every one of your conditions in our
little deal.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys.
Minto, Minto.
Can you say purple burglar alarm?
Did I say something bad just now?
I don't know.
What right do you have to complain about anything outside
our bargain?
It's a tongue twister.
Oh, okay.
We can talk about that when we get together.
This will be our last communication by telephone.
We'll arrive in one hour.
I look forward to seeing you, Sissel.
What?
How do you know me?
How, how do I, how am I know me?
How am I standing, no, how am I there?
Dawn is approaching.
The darkness surrounding my own mystery is deep, but I know
it's always darkest before the dawn.
Did I convince myself I'm Sissel, but I'm not actually
Sissel?
Huh?
Solid, am I solid, Sissel?
Wait, that, no, that is not solid Sissel.
Hmm, yes, we're nearing the final stages of our little deal,
my good man.
Yes, sir.
All preparations are complete, sir.
And we just had a report, sir.
Lights have been spotted, sir.
Lights?
Have they now?
By all means, let me have a look.
My voice being raspy, today is perfect for this guy.
Oh my gosh, we haven't seen these guys since the very
beginning.
beginning and we're on part five always there two there are
a master and an apprentice whoa that's a Star Wars reference
man thanks for the clarification aren't we actually right
and has this been VR missions this whole time yes we're very
close we will now disconnect from the communication cable
and have no service until we arrive sir wait are they in
like a ship what what do you mean very well huh arrive where
what is going on the lamp couldn't gaslight it us that's
what I feel like
wait it's zooming out oh my god wait are we really actually
on no we're underwater we're in a submarine what
Inspector Cabanella.
But you could never stop me.
Oh my gosh, he's got an evil look on his face.
Oh my god, what is going on?
Huh.
He is.
He is pretty.
He is pretty alright.
See you, sucker.
Oh my gosh, evil Cecil.
Solitus.
Cecil.
Oh my god, wait, now we get to talk to Inspector.
So, that submarine guy and his people have a deal going with
me, do they?
If that's the case, they probably aren't the ones...
Sorry, the ones that killed me, right?
Anyway, there's definitely something behind the Inspector's
death.
I think I'd better talk to him.
Where did you get that information from?
Oh, he's unconscious.
Hey, do you think you go away?
wake up for me?
Wake up!
Oh boy, still unconscious, eh?
I guess he hasn't been dead for very long, then.
See you later, alligator.
Thanks, Angel!
Thanks for the gifting!
I'll just go ahead and go back to four minutes before his
death.
I'm a little nervous about what I might see there, though.
But if that's where I was...
I'm gonna find my answers.
Oh my gosh, I can't stop yawning!
I can't run away from it.
I may need to go get some tea or something.
Once the criminal gets the punishment he deserves, the
hostage will go free.
Carry out the execution immediately and wait for our call.
Okay, this is what we saw.
Okay.
Wow.
That's a good boy.
Gee.
It sure is a handy thing.
It gives me complete control over the top police inspector
in the country.
So, Detective Cabanela isn't betraying us.
His son.
What's the matter?
Why do we have an accent all of a sudden?
All those broken bones, smart of it?
He broke his bones.
to feel pain.
Does it make you feel alive?
Wait, the sizzle is dead?
Why are you doing this?
Now, is that any kind of question for a top inspector to
ask?
Isn't it obvious?
Revenge, of course.
Oh my god!
Revenge on all the people who stole my life away 10 years
ago.
Make me feel alive again.
So he's...
Wait.
Is he possessing my body or...
So wait, we died.
I'm guessing.
I'm guessing we died and then the ghost possessed our body.
The manipulator.
Don't be ridiculous.
It was a meteorite that stole your life.
Or have you forgotten that?
Wait, but then that still doesn't explain 10 years ago.
wrong I was murdered by all of you oh my goodness my throat
maybe has multiple lives like a cat maybe detective Jowd who
chased me down and forced me into a corner even though I was
innocent Lynn that girl who was right there where I was
running we were blaming the child Lynn she was just an
innocent little girl playing in the park don't push yourself
I'll be okay, no worries.
If that brat hadn't been there, I never would have thought
of taking a hostage.
That's the most self-centered garbage I've ever heard.
And finally you, Inspector Cabanella.
Me.
If you hadn't done what you did, I never would have pointed
a gun at that kid.
Wait, what did he do?
This is a whole lot of victim-blaming, Sissel.
You were so proud of your spotless record, and my case was
the one blot on it, wasn't it?
Only two people know the real truth.
Me and Detective Jowd.
I bet tonight's execution will be quite a relief to you,
won't it?
One of the people who know about the stain on your record
will disappear for good.
That's why you didn't help him escape from prison.
Pshowd.
objection that's the kind of guy you are hmm I
got nothing to say to you you'd never listen anyway
you got now then inspector time to make a big red stain on
your spotless white coat what the oh my god he's
manipulating Everything!
He's too powerful!
This was another condition of my ideal.
To wipe out everybody who knew about Temsec.
Wait, what?
Then what about the old man?
Revenge?
That's what I'm up to!
None of this makes any sense.
Hey, man!
He's alive!
Mind telling me what's going on?
Inspector Cabanela, he's awake!
My head is spinning, baby.
Am I to understand?
That Cabanela character who just got shot is me?
Uh, that's right.
And you're supposed to be the scoundrel there who just shot
me?
I guess so.
But you couldn't be, could you?
Huh?
After all, the guy in the red suit just walked out the door.
right so who are you I don't know I don't know I guess I
just have to face it I'm not that sizzle guy I'm somebody
who's searching for himself oh poor guy what do you mean low
battery uh-oh
is it not charging
Uh oh.
Oh wait, one second, let me try this.
Oh that doesn't work.
Uh oh.
Let me try this.
Oh wait.
Um.
Ah!
I'm trying to charge my controller.
I cannot use the Joy-Cons.
No, I cannot do that.
Oh,
shoot.
I mean, maybe.
Actually, let me see.
No.
See, you can hear them?
Can you hear them?
I'm pressing the arrow.
a button, but it's not doing anything.
Why isn't it charging?
It's worked before.
Hold on.
Let me try plugging it in again.
I'll try it in again.
I think I didn't have it plugged in all the way.
Or it wasn't plugged in all the way.
Okay, now we're good.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, we're good now.
We're good.
The light is on.
Okay.
he was searching for himself okay here we go shut up shut up
everybody that's why i'm here to save you at the very least
you have information about that guy in red information i
need i'm not a clown stop no i'm not a clown so you came on
a rescue mission now did you nothing like the sound of that
baby because there's a very important life here somewhere.
A life valuable to this nation.
I get it, she's cute as ever, but extra silly.
Colonel!
Sissel, turn the game console off right now!
Were you manipulating my... my controller?
Okay.
Do your thing, baby.
Alright, four minutes before the death.
Okay, trick time.
So are you a manipulator too?
Oh, he knows what a manipulator is.
Why do we not know anything then?
Why do we not know anything about, like, you know, I think
that's kind of odd.
Like, everyone else kind of regains a little bit of their
memory.
Like, not a memory, but, like, a little bit of knowledge.
We didn't even know what kidnapping was.
You know?
How does Inspector Cabanela know what manipulator is and all
that research and everything?
He didn't know his name, but he kept everything that he
knew.
For us, we don't know anything.
My man even forgot how to read.
Yeah, we don't even know how to read.
We don't even know how to read.
Hmm.
There's something fishy here.
Like, like it doesn't feel like we were human is what I'm
getting at.
I don't know.
No spoilers, no spoilers.
I'm just cooking.
I have ghost tricks.
Powers of the dead, yeah, but I can't control living
creatures.
Anywho, I think you'd better be very careful.
A guy in red is a manipulator.
Naturally, he knows about powers like yours.
Oh!
Wait, so if I change something, is he going to...
If he realizes you're here, things might get a little
sticky.
You're right.
I'd better be careful.
That's a good boy.
Hello, ghosty hello.
Hope you're doing well today.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for the don't know.
We've, okay, we've kind of gotten all this part.
Let's see.
What can we...
Oh, look at him!
There's that something emanating from his body.
Is it really the sign of having special powers of the dead?
Okay.
Helmet.
Oh, we can get up to the book.
What is this?
The top of this bookshelf is lined with books.
This one is the top is balanced so precariously, it's a
wonder if it doesn't fall off.
old pigeon guy even reach up here.
And I wonder if he makes his pigeon fetch it for him.
The stink?
Nasty.
Okay.
What can we do with the helmet?
We can rock it.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
I think he noticed us.
Ah!
What's going on?
We've never seen the ghost world like this!
So you're here, are you?
He sensed my presence!
Uh-oh.
Me?
Wait a minute.
I notice you.
You think you can stop me, do you?
Oh my god.
He's looking at me!
I don't know why you're wearing my face.
But you might as well give up now.
I control everything.
Damn it.
No, it doesn't work!
It doesn't work!
Everything, including the life of this police inspector and
what?
Wait, don't shoot!
Oh my god.
So we can't make any obvious movements.
That's crazy.
This other me knows the powers of the dead well.
Who wouldn't notice what you just did?
You were practically shouting, look at me, baby.
It looks like it might be hard to save you under these
circumstances.
I guess I can't use my powers right in front of him like
that.
Interesting.
I was curious what would happen if he noticed us.
So interesting.
So cool.
Okay.
Oh my god he looked straight at me.
It's kind of freaky.
Not saying I would do this but are we allowed to gift you
weapons?
Like are we allowed to give you weapons?
maybe a sword um no as much as i would love to accept that i
don't think i can um
but also if this is for off kai after off kai i'm going to
japan so um i would like the gifts to be smaller so that I
can fit them in my suitcase yeah there and back yeah
oh my gosh I would be that would be awesome to get a sword
though that'd be so cool wait there's I if I open this will
the same thing happen or close it oh okay we gotta wait for
it to heat up, I think.
And go...
What's the matter?
Oh, those broken bones smart a bit.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh!
Never mind.
Okay.
He didn't even give us time to...
Oh, but now we're closer here.
Okay, perfect.
And...
Oh!
Wait, everything's destroyed!
What about a...
calm.
I won it!
PSA, do not give weapons to the dangerous VTuber.
It's not for my safety, it's for yours.
Look at this place.
The whole thing, the whole contraption is destroyed!
Is the old man dead?
What in the world happened here?
I think I'm starting to remember.
bad happened here and now there's another death lion lying
hidden here i knew it what another death didn't i tell you
from the start didn't i say there was a very important life
value valuable to the nation here he wasn't talking about
himself i thought you were talking about you i'm just a
crazy character and a white coat baby oh his little bird is
sad Okay, come to think of it.
Where is that old pigeon guy?
Okay, we don't have much time.
Move it down.
Or...
Oh, like that, exactly.
There he is!
Oh, little bird.
Little bird.
This is some kind of a device.
Very astute observation.
Sorry, my memory isn't working.
and working too well right now either.
But I do remember seeing somebody use this equipment,
though.
I gotta open this thing.
Yeah, there we go.
So sad.
It's too sad.
Okay, let's talk to the doctor.
Let me excuse me.
Are you awake?
Of course.
I never sleep during work hours.
Professor, do you recognize me?
There's only one crazy character in a white coat that I know
of.
He hasn't lost his memory.
I'm not the type who likes losing things.
But never mind that.
Cabanella, this is quite a surprising guest you've brought
with you.
Pretending like he didn't just blow up the place.
Oh, shoot.
We're trying to hide the evidence.
Are you talking about me?
Well, this is a different guy.
And I'm his guest, actually.
Said he came to rescue us.
Why is the bird there, too?
The bird is always with him in spirit.
Unlike you, my sharp friend, he still hasn't gotten his
memory back.
Hmph.
Pitiful.
Ouch.
That hurts.
Anyway, now we'll be going back to four minutes before your
death.
In order to change your fate, that is.
But aren't we already in the past, man?
But we can go back even further!
I've done it before.
I still don't see a path to saving Inspector Cabanella.
But if we go back further, maybe I'll find a lead.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
We're rewinding even further!
Going beyond!
Okay.
Ghostception.
What the?
How many times do I have to tell you, Professor?
This place is dangerous.
Ugh.
Don't be daft.
I can't leave now.
Wait, what is he doing with Cicil's body?
He's completely dead.
But just as I thought, I'm getting a reading.
This is the source of his powers.
If I remove it...
He's not dead.
He's just not there.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
The true form of the manipulator isn't something you can
detect.
It's a spirit!
Hmm, ridiculous.
So you figured it all out, huh?
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun,
dun, dun.
Hold on, I have a cool effect.
I have a cool effect for Evil Sissel.
You're a clever man, Inspector Cabanella.
So it's really true.
You're...
I wasted a lot of time tonight because of you, Inspector.
Spooky.
But it's all just like you said.
died 10 years ago this body is just a vessel a shell i
control everything the shell people just like i controlled
the justice minister and lynn
evil mint hot wait a second
so it's true you were manipulating my baby that time you
made her shoot your shell but why why would you do a thing
like that to create conclusive evidence you know on that
security tape now she's a murderer too she'll suffer just
like Zhao did go back I have to I have to do it for the
character you guys now then professor but imagine you guys
imagine I put on I put on wait do I have it oh wait I don't
think I'd be able to get it right now thank you I can't if I
put on an eye patch I would be just like riding
able mint kawaii I'm afraid it's time for you to die I don't
have any grudge against you.
I'm even grateful to you.
Doctor!
Oh, yeah.
So why don't you let me live then?
I'll be leaving this country forever tonight.
But before I do, I need to erase all evidence that these
powers of mine exist.
Along with the contraption in this room.
Oh my god.
Wait!
bomb the bomb the bomb the bomb the bomb wait who this time
the thing will work the way it was meant to and it'll be
it'll be all over wait but like why don't you just like all
you have to do is like use your finger and go on the on the
fire and then it's fixed evil mint please come crawling out
of my computer Okay.
Cupid won't turn this time.
He'll shoot his little arrow this way.
Professor look out!
Wait, how did he know that there was a bomb there?
How did he survive that?
Dynamite, eh?
When the devil did he put that there?
That's what I'm saying!
He planned it all out tonight.
my baby shoot him having his corpse disappear his corpse
disappeared wait 10 years ago no oh yeah when we were
sitting there right that medical examiner remember him he
was a complete and utter impasse i i said it i called it i
called guy is probably in kahoot's with them i
i called it i called it
i mean maybe i I was being a little judgmental.
But, um.
I don't know.
He said he was going to take the corpse back to the lab.
But he'd already made a deal.
But he also was acting kind of sussy, you know.
He already made a deal with the manipulator to meet him and
give him the body back.
But I wasn't going to let that happen, baby.
You saw through their play.
I noticed right away the medical examiner didn't know the
first thing about examining a body he was being weird I knew
he was a fake so I tracked him down and bought him off oh my
god dang he's a he's a triple crosser bought him off I had
him smuggle the corpse to this room oh I thought we could
find the source of his powers.
Of course, never in my wildest dreams did I think his
abilities were powers of the dead.
Hmm.
Anyway, there isn't much time.
He's leaving the country before dawn.
That's why I have until dawn, probably.
And I'm gonna follow him, of course, after I save you two.
But something's been nagging at the back of my mind.
I remember what Ray said to me tonight.
He said that spirits cease to exist when the day breaks.
But if that's true, how could a spirit from 10 years ago
still be here?
Cabanela is Ocelot?
No!
The doctor is Ocelot.
Except he's like, so inconsequential.
Yeah, I think Ray was lying.
I think I mentioned that last stream too.
No time for thinking now, baby.
Action is the name of the game.
Work your magic and take us back even further into the past.
Hmm.
Okay.
If only...
If only they had...
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't realize.
I thought I pressed Cabanilla's text.
He said, stop the explosion.
Foolish of you to say, too.
If you stop the explosion, just do me in some other way.
Fair enough.
Then jump in there and take care of that man in red, would
you?
I repeat, easy enough for you to say.
And most likely impossible to boot.
That huge explosion didn't even make him bat an eye.
We gotta tie him up.
Well, what do you propose then, Professor?
Pray tell.
Your best bet is to save me during the explosion without him
noticing.
How is that our best bet?
bet this puzzle is tough to figure out how how how how is
that our best bet why don't we just tie him up and not let
him touch anything easy enough for you to say sheesh what's
with all these people any who jump in there and do something
okay okay my guess is when the explosion happens we open up
the door and have him fall down.
Right?
So that way he wouldn't notice that
that way he wouldn't notice that he doesn't die.
But I also can't move anywhere.
Oh wait, here we go.
Okay.
Fool, what do you think you're doing?
Oh, I just thought I'd try it out.
If you do, you're going to set the contraption in motion.
Just put the fire out.
Oh yeah, I just thought.
He just thought he'd blow me up is what he thought.
Oops, that was my bad.
There aren't a whole lot of things I can use my tricks on in
this room.
Yeah, exactly.
Uh...
Why don't you just set the...
You can move the fire away!
I need him to move back.
towards me.
Can you turn this way, sir?
I can't reach.
Oh, maybe here?
There we go.
Okay.
Do I have to wait?
No, I feel like it has to be something else that I can do.
I'm gonna see what happens if I go all the way until the end
and drop him down, right?
Oh, but he doesn't...
S...
stand.
Oh, there.
Okay, now he does stand on the door.
Okay, nice.
Time is passing.
What if I drop a note?
Oh, it's no use.
I can't.
Oh, I can't.
The fact that Professor is standing on it, have anything to
do with it?
I may look small, but I'm pretty heavy set.
He sounds so proud of that fact, too.
This door, such a pity.
Too bad it doesn't open downward.
Sometimes life can be so hard.
No, that's why we're both dead.
A door that opens downward, eh?
A door that opens downward?
What is going on in here?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Dum, dum, dum, dum, dum.
As you perhaps may have already noticed, time is running
out, baby.
Yeah, know perhaps about it.
I know.
But you know, there aren't a whole lot of things and use my
ghost tricks on in here.
Looks like it's all over.
Unless I find another path, I'm sort of out of deadlock
here.
Sizzle.
Who is this?
I know that voice.
Help me.
Where are you?
Find me.
Before I'm carried away.
What's with that frail sounding call for help?
He's here somewhere!
Is it Ray?
The lamp?
Missile?
Oh, it's a missile!
A little guy that looks a little fragile but has strength
that surprise you!
Well, he's asking you to find him!
And before, he's carried away, no less.
But I'm almost out of time.
Should I look for him?
Okay, uh...
I can't reach!
Oh no!
Wait!
Um,
if I can stop this toy from spinning, I can halt the
contraption without really solving anything.
There is a smart boy.
If you stop the explosion, they'll find another way to get
me.
It would probably give you the...
Give away the fact that you're here too.
So I have to rescue you without stopping the explosion.
Is that even possible?
That's what has to be done.
Deal with it.
Can I reach?
I can't reach!
How do I...
Do I just look around?
Oh!
Cecil!
Here I am!
It's Meso!
What are you doing there?
Do you really have to ask?
Seriously, are you really going there?
Uh, no, that's okay.
Never mind.
Anyway, I need your powers.
Will you help me out?
Of course!
Here, let me come join you!
Um...
Okay.
Very good.
Here I am, sisal.
Wait, but I think I've lost too much time, I think.
Wait, no.
We just have to figure out before...
As the explosion happens, so...
We have to figure it out as the explosion happens.
Maybe things will flow in a new direction.
Even though the flow of the sewer is a little bit stinky.
Fate has changed.
Kind of.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
YZR.
What are some things that are the same?
Measuring device, toolbox, motor.
Is there anything that's like the same shape?
Thanks for the super chat!
The toy cake.
It's kind of similar to the tool.
Oh, well, you can't reach that floor, though.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe...
No, no, no.
Maybe down here.
Oh, wait.
Actually, what about the rats?
Here, here, here.
Trash can lid.
Trash can.
What's this?
What was going on?
Those squeaky guys are making a fuss about something.
Cicel.
My animal instincts are starting to thwart.
If you mean you want to chase them, I think you have to be
alive to do that.
Hmm.
There must be some kind of rat feast in that trash can.
Those things usually make a bigger commotion than that.
Bigger commotion, eh?
What does that mean?
Oh!
Swap.
Okay, they're inside the feast.
What's in here?
What's going on?
Oh, more rats are coming!
Oh, what's going on?
Why are there so many rats?
Now that's what I'd call some proper commotion.
They're making that trash can dance.
Truth be told, I feel a bit like dancing now myself.
It's getting harder and harder to hold my wild instincts
back.
What a dangerous bunch.
Wait, I have like no time!
Oh, oh.
What's going on?
Trash can lid.
I don't know what I just did.
I don't... Wait, the trash can lid.
Oh no.
I thought the trash can lid and the tire could change.
Switch!
What does that do?
I have a trash can lid here now.
don't know what I don't know what else to do with it now
it's flat and we can switch it wait we can switch the lid
with ah oh okay okay I got I got it.
But we have to wait until it explodes, I think.
Oh my gosh, that's so tricky.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I think if it explodes, it's too late.
You have zero seconds?
Okay, switch!
Look out!
Oh, there we go.
Okay!
Easy peasy.
Oh.
Cabanilla's not dead though.
He's not dead.
Sorry.
Oh.
Cah!
Sorry, little pigeon.
Oh my god.
Look at the, look at the position, the legging.
As for you, Inspector.
little job for you.
I can't move.
I think I have four or five broken bones.
I don't mind.
It won't prevent me from manipulating you.
It might make it hurt a little bit when I move you, though.
Quite a bit, actually.
Damn you!
No!
He's so cute.
Oh, wait.
She's alive.
First try, nice work.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
You lot actually pulled it off.
Sorry, Inspector Cabanella.
I couldn't do anything to help you.
And there I am.
A poor broken heap of arms and legs.
But no matter.
I enjoyed the shell.
The magic disappearing act, that is.
Nothing like it, baby.
Yeah, his name's Lovidobby.
No way, it's so cute.
Do you guys mind if I have some...
Pringles?
I'm kind of hungry.
I bought some Minecraft Pringles.
So I can get coins.
Except...
Thank you, thank you.
Chew.
Richa, minto.
With some help from the world's finest best doggle.
Oh, sorry.
The world's finest.
The world's best doggle.
Yes!
I haven't had brinkles in so long, I got them because they
had minecraft on them.
You get 350 minecoins!
Who wouldn't get them?
Unlike a normal magic trick, I'm the one that managed to
vanish without a trace here.
Okay nice.
You want some?
Say ah!
What do you do with minecoins?
you can buy it's for the bedrock version not the Java
version you can buy certain worlds they have a Jurassic Park
world you guys a Jurassic Park Minecraft world they have a
Godzilla Minecraft world Godzilla you can fight as Godzilla
and you fight like Mothra and stuff like that it's so
awesome yeah they have a Mega Man X world it's crazy what's
the matter you look like you'd rather be dead not that you
aren't i'll just remember in the fact that right about now
the real me is giving the poor justice minister a real
fright oh that phone call yeah he was pretty upset um excuse
me mister miss you really shouldn't be mean like that And
what's this lively little creature?
Oh, this little doggy is the warrior who keeps Camilla safe.
Or he would be if he was actually still full of life.
Wait a second.
I just realized, how are we going to go back to save
Missile?
How does this not create a time paradox?
If we're...
How do we go back and save Missile?
Camilla God's in heaven What a terrible thing That poor
little girl taking hostage It's a cruel twist of fate indeed
Wait a minute Miss Camilla is a hostage Yes, we're sorry
little warrior Miss Camilla A hostage What's a hostage?
Anyway, Inspector Cavanella your life now but you couldn't
get very far when you tried before am i right i love missile
but this time it's different right sisle that's right with
us working together it's a whole different situation we'll
save the inspector in white and then we'll go rescue camilla
okay okay let's hurry up and get through this gee kids
you're making me feel like an afterthought apologize to
cabanella you're right i should I thought he betrayed us.
I thought he was a bad guy the whole time to be honest.
No, he was a good guy
It's a good red herring.
It is yeah
Hmm.
Okay, let's get started.
Inspector Cabanela is upstairs So our first step is to get
up there Cecil, I'll go up first and wait for you.
Wait.
Oh
Can you help me out mister?
Okay, lovey dove.
It's so cute.
We need your help.
Carry this measuring device upstairs.
It has Mr. Ghost in it, so don't drop it.
No!
Thank you, Lovidov.
Oh, oh, so close.
So close.
Just a little bit more.
Oh, wait.
I missed the...
Sorry, I missed the prompt.
Okay.
We're upstairs.
There you are, Sissel!
Sorry for the wait, Missile.
If you want to see the best death in the game, let the
situation with Cabanella play out without doing anything.
Really?
Okay, we'll do that.
Four minutes from now, the inspector will be killed by a
gun.
You just jump in there and stop him from firing, would you?
There you go again with that stuff.
Besides, it doesn't make any sense.
If you stop him from firing, he'll just kill you some other
way.
Wait a minute, that sounds familiar.
Yep, same situation as mine.
Your best bet is this time around, is to allow him to shoot
and then save Cabanella without him noticing.
It's even worse than last time.
Anywho, jump in there and do something.
I'm ready to jump in, Sissel.
Oh, wait, so don't do anything?
So I'm just gonna watch.
I'm gonna eat my Pringles and watch.
Okay.
Time is passing.
Did you see that?
That bad sisle turned around!
Do you have to call him that?
But yeah, maybe this is our chance to try and do some ghost
tricks.
It's the only time he takes his eyes off of me too.
Do you have something to do?
Okay.
No, I don't think I will.
I think I'm gonna...
Objection.
Nothing to say to you.
Dang, he ragdolls over there so crazy like.
It's like he got no bones.
Is this all right?
Oh, they see.
Sam.
I'm a little scared right now.
Why didn't he die?
Because he's already dead.
He died ten years ago.
I knew full well he wouldn't die if I shot him.
And why did you go to the trouble of shooting him at all?
Time's almost up.
That's enough, Chit Chat.
But now the situation has changed slightly.
These last split seconds are our chance.
They are?
Okay.
Wait a second.
Oh, there's a motor.
Let's see.
What goes on?
This was...
Oh, another condition.
Wipe out everybody that knows about...
He's going to shoot!
It's too late!
Again?
I'm going to get shot again?
No, wait!
Our chance is coming up!
The last split second, right?
Leave it to me!
Will you?
Would you look at that?
hanging in mid-air between the gun and the inspector's
forehead!
Now's our chance!
Wait, I'm here in the bullet right now!
Let's swap this little thing with something else!
Wait, what?
It's our only hope, it is?
Wait, there's gotta be something here with the same shape
and direction as the bullet!
Uh...
Hurry now!
Swap that hanging bullet with something else!
Oh.
That's a bullet?
What?
What is the bullet even shape?
I can't even tell what the shape is.
I can't even tell.
Is it with the hard hat?
Oh my god.
No way.
Is this gonna work?
Oh.
That didn't go.
Oh my god.
We tried swapping.
We'll be confined, but we just made things worse.
Not nice, kids.
Not nice at all.
You put a dent in my lovely...
Oh no.
I don't have a napkin.
Oh wait, maybe I do.
No, I don't have a napkin.
Because we bought her...
to swap with.
From the beginning means from this beginning, right?
Not from the doctor's beginning.
Oh, oh, wait.
I want to see what he says here.
You've got grit, little pigeon.
I better get up there before the little pigeon's strength
that gives out.
Missile's waiting for me.
I better hurry.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, give me...
Don't worry, everybody falls for that.
Give me one second.
I'm going to go wash my hands.
and get some more water.
Sorry for the intermission.
Mid-puzzle.
But give me one second.
I have no napkin and I have a dirty hand.
I mean, I don't want to use my sleeves, even though they
cover my hands.
But, you know.
And I was out of hot water.
I couldn't get any more water at all.
Sorry.
Oh, I left for no reason.
and I filled up my thing again so um so uh it's boiling now
hmm you don't have a kettle that's what I'm using
hmm thanks for all the super chat thank you guys I actually
got this puzzle wrong the first time because I didn't know
what a bullet in flight was shaped like.
That's, that's, that's weird, right?
Okay.
Once it's fired, the bullet will be the key to the whole
thing.
Okay.
Use my powers.
So, trick time.
Uh, we have to find something soft that is the shape of the
helmet.
How do we get it over there, though?
That's literally it.
Oh, but we don't reach Hmm
Oh wait We can move through the step ladder Help me step
ladder I'm stuck Wait Wait
ZR Oh, I can't reach there either I'm so useless Wait, I'm
stuck here Wait Wait!
Wait!
Oh wait, we have to wait for him to set it down, that's
right.
I remember, I remember.
Okay.
Chance!
Oh, wait.
Ah, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, oh, oh, he's gonna turn around.
Time is passing.
Swevel!
La la la.
Don't notice me.
Rock.
Wait, if I rock it now, will he notice?
Oh.
Oopsie.
What was that?
Oh, I think I made things worse.
Uh-oh.
Oopsie!
Oh, wait.
No, because it would still launch the helmet.
It would still launch the helmet.
Like, it would still go, you know?
Pew.
Because it would be in motion.
How do I get over there, though?
How do I get over there?
I can't be as long as you.
Hmm.
What was that noise?
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Ah!
Oh.
Oh, it's closer.
It's closer.
I forgot that.
I forgot that that happened.
ZR.
Wait, why is the music stopped?
La la la la la la la la la la.
Oh, that's why the music stopped.
Oh no!
Jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle!
Okay, now go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Move, move, move, move, move, move, move!
Now, I think we should be able to do it.
I think.
Now we just wait, right?
Is Missile gonna intercept again?
Oh, it looks like the book!
Oh, the shape!
Oh, you're right.
Oh, you're right, it's too flat.
Oh, no!
Oh, okay, I shouldn't have moved the helmet on the ground.
I should have kept it up there.
Ah!
Okay, okay.
I get it now.
Okay, we'll restart.
We'll restart.
Are you sure?
Don't reset?
Okay.
I'll try it.
Even when my powers is nothing I can do.
Swap the bullet with...
Sorry, Inspector.
Oh, bobo, bobo, bobo.
Wait.
Swap?
No, it's just hanging there.
Oh, oh, I get it.
Okay, I didn't realize that it would like...
If I swapped it with the book, it would then slide down.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I get it now, I get it.
Okay, okay, okay.
So I still had to rock it to the ground.
Or like rock it, knock it over.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
No worries, no worries.
Okay.
I get it.
The game spoiled her.
Yeah, pretty much.
It's all a waiting game for most of this.
though.
So here we gotta wait.
We gotta wait.
La la la la la la la la.
BAM!
Okay.
Then from here, we go here.
We go here, we go here.
And we, oh, no.
Just kidding.
We go here.
And we wait for him to turn around.
Objection.
Spin!
Chup, chup, and rock.
what was that noise nothing nothing here now I wait for him
to get shot yeah and I have to go really fast.
Pieu!
Nice.
Just to hide.
Trick time.
Okay.
Oh,
I need you to move.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go Rock it!
Jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle, jiggle jiggle,
jiggle, jiggle Move it!
Move it!
Okay, uh...
Swap it!
Pop it!
Twist it!
Beep!
Swap it!
Whop!
Okay, and then Oh.
But you look at that right on the hook.
I love knit hats.
So warm and most of all, soft.
Why are you in my head?
Now that I'm looking at it, that hat is the same shape as
the helmet that you just knocked down.
Aha!
I thought so.
Yes.
Now we'll intercept with a fuzzy hat.
Bing!
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Oh, I freaking...
For so many times I was like, missile?
Missile?
Missile!
Bullet with hat!
Swap!
Boom!
Oh!
Oh my god, he is freaking dead!
Oh, he just totally didn't think anything of it.
I don't think he noticed.
Looks like he pulled off another magic disappearing act.
And now I say again, I love Natats.
So warm and most of all, soft.
Did I, did I do all right?
You did a fine job, little one.
Go, Missile!
Wait, you, wait, you guys, you guys, Did- did I do a good
job?
Did- did- did Mint do a good job?
Ear scratches for everyone.
Minto de Grey.
You saved another life.
And I'll keep doing it too.
Over and over.
good job mint thank you what I just what I saw in just these
four minutes give me all the answers I've been looking for
all I research these past 10 years pales in comparison right
professor yeah all I had to do was die so you two were
working together that's about the size of a yeah who would
believe a story about a manipulator so we pursued it
ourselves It's just the two of us.
I wonder if the knit hat is a reference to Hobo Phoenix R-
Hobo Hodo.
Maybe.
It is the same color.
If it had a little button on it, then it for sure would be,
right?
Or it would be the other way around.
Maybe Phoenix's hat is a reference to this, right?
Because this game came...
I'm assuming this game came out after...
I mean, before A.S.
Apollo Justice, right?
Takumi didn't work on Hobo Rite.
didn't oh oh it was after this game was in 2009 oh i see i
see i see
huh how can we help produce apollo i think
i'm quite a crazy character myself after all okay let's
hurry back back to our time Thank you!
Fortunately, I'm gonna have to miss the end of this game due
to sleep, but I hope you enjoy it.
It's only gonna get twistier.
Really?
From here, even twistier!
I'm excited.
Thank you!
We have to rescue Miss Camilla!
You're right, Missile.
And there's a certain guy I have to follow too.
Yeah, me!
Me!
I have to follow me!
Hmm.
wake up wake up inspector it was the performance of a
lifetime after completing his revenge on inspector cavanella
the man in red left and now a new story is about to unfold
and a new present we saved two people how are you feeling
you old crazy character
what the ghost doing hey there prof we're both alive I see
yeah nothing like it baby but I don't know if I'm getting
old or what I've got a few aches and pains here and there
used to be a little thing like an explosion used to be a
little thing like an explosion wouldn't bother me yeah right
like I'm going to believe that so what the guy in red is
gone eh just in case I posted special investigation units
around the building.
Let's just pray the boys came through for us.
What if they got paid off though?
You can't trust anybody.
Not even yourself, apparently.
Damn it.
You've picked a bad time not to listen to me, buddy of mine.
Inspector Cabanella is so cool.
You got this.
Trick time.
Uh.
Well, it looks like both of their deaths were erased.
Unfortunately, in the case of the I mean, how are you
supposed to stop his bones being broken from an explosion?
But it might, but in any case, these two have the
information I need to start tracking the manipulator.
I'd better talk to them.
I want to talk to the bird.
How is Missal doing?
All right, Sisal, it's time to go!
Out into the big wide world to rescue Miss Camilla!
Hold on a minute, Missal.
I have to talk to these two first.
Oh.
Okay.
I understand.
But just know one thing.
I go where the wind takes me.
Is this little doggy trying to put pressure on me?
Okay.
Let's talk.
Mr. Superintendent.
Do you mind if I talk to you for a minute?
I haven't always been a junkyard superintendent.
Intendant.
Superintendent.
Superintendent, you know.
I used to be part of the police.
The police, huh?
He's like a leaf in the wind.
Super Nintendo.
No.
Not as a detective, but as a medical examiner.
I investigated victims' cause of death.
Ooh.
Like mine?
Ten years ago, I was asked to autopsy a strange corpse.
Hit by a meteorite fragment and died instantly.
That's what the police report said.
Well, what if the police report is wrong, too?
What if everything is wrong?
There were no signs of life.
He was definitely dead.
But I never filed an autopsy report.
That's because the corpse suddenly vanished.
Leaving behind only one clue.
An unusual clue.
Corpse.
I bet that's what I've been chasing all night.
Wouldn't it be like soul?
It would be bones.
It would just be bones.
We'd be a walking skeleton.
Could you tell me more?
Yeah, sure.
I have an interest in you recovering your memory and finding
your true identity too.
Unusual corpse.
That's the only way I can describe it to.
It was an unusual corpse.
Oh, he was dead alright.
No question about that.
But there wasn't a scratch on him.
Not a scratch, but I thought he was hit by a meteorite
fragment.
Spooky scary skeletons and shivers down your spine.
You gotta manipulate the blood flow and flow of nutrients.
I don't understand it any more than you do.
Okay.
it's aliens aliens aliens I was completely bewildered but
when I tried to autopsy him I was even more puzzled I
couldn't perform the autopsy it's like he's like
manipulating the body but trying to be kind of like
inconspicuous about it so it's just like or sorry
conspicuous about it so he's just like he'll like go in with
the knife and the hand just kind of shoots up like maybe
that's not very conspicuous at all actually wait is it
inconspicuous or conspicuous now i'm confused i don't know
wait which one inconspicuous equals subtle subtle okay okay
i switched them around i had it right the first time
confused you okay now I remember I thought I had it right
you couldn't what do you mean the scalpel went in but I
couldn't cut as soon as I tried to make an incision it would
heal up in the very next instant that's how it went and no
scarring your blood either.
The rock makes you immortal?
And I never had the chance to solve the mystery.
That's because the corpse up and vanished on us.
The morgue is well guarded.
Nobody could have stolen that body.
But there is one way the corpse could have disappeared.
What's that?
If he just got up and walked out himself.
He's bisexual.
Vamp.
It got up, opened the door, and walked out on its own.
Wait, is that on the security camera?
What?
He was dead, but he wasn't dead.
We saw it with our own eyes tonight.
Not even that explosion could kill him.
And he didn't even feel it when he slammed his fist onto
that stove.
The corpse left behind some data from some...
Blip, blip, blip!
The corpse left behind some data from some testing I did.
I got some readings for some kind of radiation.
Coming off the body!
No wonder this town is so kooky!
They're all... they all have radiation poisoning!
No wonder everyone is so eccentric!
Oh my god!
Radiation.
Radioactive!
I used all kinds of instruments, but I couldn't determine
exactly what kind of radiation it was.
Sub- Sorry.
I'm a discovered type.
From a world unknown.
Wait a minute.
Could it be?
That's right.
It was coming from that meteorite fragment.
Aliens, aliens, aliens!
Oh my gosh, I'm getting super outer wild vibes right now.
Just because I'm thinking of, like, the rock and outer
wilds, you know, and how it was so mysterious.
Ghost of matter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I'm thinking of the one that when you turn around, it
would disappear.
I went to that park and tested the spot where the meteorite
fell.
coming from that creator.
It was the exact same pattern of radiation as that of the
corpse.
Yes, the quantum rock!
Yes, yes, yes.
At the time, I thought he was some kind of immortal being.
He would die only to come back to life.
I wanted to research it all in depth, so I quit my job as a
police medical examiner.
Several years later, I came to learn the connection between
my research.
I'm so sorry I keep you all.
I'm so sorry.
My research and the manipulator case.
Thanks to the arrival of this crazy character here.
Oh, stop now, Professor.
Do you want to see me blush?
Cabanella's arrival.
Please continue.
I gotta get more water.
It was about a year ago, I say.
Akubi, tascar!
Tascara not!
This man in white came dancing into my research lab here.
Mint, are you the byproduct of radiation too?
Um...
Am I a freak?
I don't glow at night.
I don't glow in the dark.
Sometimes.
I don't know.
You are green?
Wait, I am a freak!
I'm a freaky ghost maid!
I think we should explore this later.
I heard there was an oddball here who's researching Temsik.
Is that you, baby?
Like how he calls everybody, baby.
Even to the old man scientist.
Who are you to be calling anybody an oddball?
Maybe I came from outer space.
Uranium rod.
Maybe I'm actually an alien.
Maan, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Wow, what convinced you, Maan?
Did you think like, oh my gosh, she's an alien?
I love aliens.
You know?
Space, ghost, coast to coast!
The dots keep connecting, you guys.
kind of crazy.
The thoughts keep connecting.
I was investigating the manipulator case then.
And then I heard there was a man
who'd quit the police force to study the meteorite.
When I heard that, it was like a meteorite had struck me on
the head.
Oh, look at all of them.
Oh my gosh, wait, I completely forgot about the guy on the
left.
The guy who has his toes out.
At the time, we were just starting to get leads on this
manipulator.
We didn't know who he was yet.
Spacemento!
But we knew he was communicating with a certain foreign
country.
In one of those communications, we heard the manipulator say
this.
The source of my power is not of this world.
End transmission.
And that's when I put two and two together, baby.
The manipulator case and Temsik were somehow connected.
Which also explained how five years ago he used his powers
to manipulate a birthday surprise a little girl made by her
mother.
He added that gun to the contraption, most likely by
controlling Camilla.
You're starting to freak me out.
What's wrong?
If I haven't served you freaking you out from the beginning,
I'm not doing my job as a the ghost well enough honestly all
right now we talk to cabanella if i knew things were going
to end up like this i would have tried to die in that
explosion baby that way i could have been dancing after big
red by now i might be able to erase deaths but it's true i
can't do much about injuries but really you shouldn't talk
that way yeah sorry i suppose you're right i just hate
feeling so helpless he was right there within my grasp I
just missed the puzzle sorry all our plans were resting on
tonight and then this this had to happen guess he's thinking
about his spotless record it's not too late inspector we
still have a chance maybe I can catch him say you're right
that's not a bad idea I'll cooperate with you fully go ahead
and fire away with any questions you like mr.
ghost okay i'm gonna go get my water now and i'm actually
gonna get some caffeine too because i know we're in we're
it's gonna be a long while to finish this so i gotta be not
yawning every two seconds so i'm so sorry it's gonna be a
little oh my gosh i'm so sorry for the second break i'm
gonna make a little note getting water getting Oh no, I have
hiccups!
No!
I have hiccups.
Getting water and energy.
No!
Please no.
Oh no, no, no, no!
I hate it.
Oh wait, actually?
Okay, I'll be right back.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Brie or Brie.
I'm back.
Oh my god, I almost spilled my drink.
I have two drinks.
okay okay I'm so sorry everybody I didn't want to leave two
times but um yes I'm back sorry VOD watchers so sorry
everybody are the hiccups gone yeah they're gone yippee I
don't know where to put the second drink I'll put it there
okay okay we kept the VOD watchers entertained you did
what'd you do what'd you do what'd you do you could see me
scooting up in my chair okay okay whoa why am i so loud
sorry about that whoosh okay now we're good to ask about
revenge a guy mentioned revenge revenge against the people
who stole his life away 10 years ago he's a fool he's the
one who made the decision to take that little girl hostage
and he wound up He only has himself to blame.
It's true.
But what about when he said this?
Oh, that it was a lie.
Yeah, right?
I was murdered by all of you.
Detective Jowd, who forced me into a corner.
Lynn, the girl who was playing in the park.
And finally, you, Inspector Cabanella.
If you hadn't done what you did, I never would have pointed
a gun at that kid.
Mmm.
Mmm...
Spill the beans, Cabanella.
Ten years ago, on that day, the special investigation unit
was working on a certain big case.
We hauled in a young man, an important witness to our
investigation.
And then I did it.
I made two very stupid mistakes.
Oh.
Detective, I'm telling you!
I don't know anything about it!
fine you're under no obligation to talk of course but if you
don't the special investigation unit can make the rest of
your life a living hell what he's a witness why are you if
he's just a witness why are you interrogating him like
this the first mistake was being a big meanie but what I I
just been assigned to the special investigation unit you see
they didn't share much information on big cases with a
newbie like me yet.
And I wanted to impress them.
Good cop, bad cop?
No!
It was only supposed to be a simple matter of taking a
statement.
But I was too green.
Me!
I'm green.
I'm a mix of blue, too.
I pushed him too hard.
I drove him into a corner and made him lose all hope.
That was my first mistake.
And then I made him another mistake on top of that.
He was too minty.
It ain't easy being...
It ain't...
Inti being minty.
Cabanello, got a minute?
The chief wants to see you about your report.
Oh no, you left him in there!
Got it.
I'll be right there.
You stay right here and be a good boy now.
Oh my god, is that why he said good boy to Cabanello?
Oh my god.
He's been thinking about that for a long time.
That's when I did it.
I left it behind in the interrogation room.
My gun!
Oh my god, you're so...
What?
How could you?
He used my gun to escape.
escape.
What he said is true.
If I hadn't made that mistake, he never would have had a gun
to point at Lynn in the first place.
Fire this guy.
I know, right?
How is he not fired?
Manipulator.
We first found out about the manipulator's existence during
a certain overseas communication.
Overseas communication.
For national security purposes, this country keeps networks.
This particular communication was about making a deal with a
certain foreign country.
Cicel, you said you'd say put him be a good boy.
Oh my god, you guys.
I sometimes say that to Paz.
But I actually think I have to rename her Johnny.
Oh my god.
This morning, I think I'm so tired because this morning was
a little bit stressful for me and that i was just cleaning
up so much shit i'm never i i went down to pet her and i pet
her she was looking out the window i pet her and i my my
hand was wet
and then and then i looked at her i was like what and then i
just saw poop all over her poop everywhere And then she was,
like, walking on the couch.
She was walking everywhere.
It's Johnny.
Have you taken her to the vet?
Well, I've changed her food a couple times.
So, I know, like, I've been, it's, it's...
When I got her, I tried weaning her off the food that they
gave me that she was used to.
But, she didn't, she wouldn't eat it.
And so, I started giving her a new food, and then she had a
bad tummy ache, and I was like, I don't know, I can't
pinpoint the problem.
Oh, I'm like, is she, is she, like, have the sensitive
stomach to something, or?
I had a shitty kitty, it sucked.
Oh, I've never had.
She's not using the box.
No, she is, she is, she is.
It's just, she poops liquid.
well sometimes not always oh it's just it's been so bad it's
been so stressful on me i'm just cleaning up poop all the
time oh it's so bad
allergy i thought that might be the case so i've tried like
you know i was like maybe The worst of it was when she had
chicken, and so I thought maybe she can't have chicken.
And then I would try something else, and then she would
still be poopy.
Oh, man.
Everything is poop.
I know, my God.
Thanks, Austin, a lot for the super chat.
Anyway, sorry about that.
Why did I think about that?
Why did I think about my cat's poop?
Have you went to the vet to check their stomach?
Not yet.
Actually, I had to take Bhutaro to the emergency vet like
literally a couple days ago.
I had to take him to the emergency vet.
it's just been I'm like oh my god I've just been running
back and forth to vets over and over and over and over and
over and over again I might have had a minor breakdown about
it today when I was cleaning up shit so I think that's why
I'm so tired is he okay yeah he's okay he's fine he had a
cold and he wasn't getting over it so I just had to get him
some extra antibiotics so yeah hmm Anyway.
Vet cost.
Oh my god.
I've probably...
Yeah, I don't even want to think about how much I've spent
on...
Luckily, I'm in a position where I can afford it, right?
But...
Oh god.
But But But Butato's doing much better now.
He got...
He got his shots.
He got some...
antibiotic shots and stuff so yeah survival
of the fittest cats no
is youtube finally paying you oh my gosh i got paid today
yes i got paid i got paid yippee oh my gosh no thank you for
that guys oh but please don't like you have to please
actually i feel like i could sit i could have sent dozens of
vacas with the vet bills when my cat was having seizures ah
oh i know oh i know i know please no don't send though
actually like it's it's it's it's okay it's all good it's
all good it's all good i don't need like extra or anything
i'm all good are you sure yes i'm i'm 100 percent you guys
already do so much as it is so yeah anyway this particular
let's get back to the game right this particular
communication was about making a deal with a certain foreign
country oh he said he wanted them to buy him whoa you can
see his outline whoa it looks like wait can you Can you guys
see it?
An OBS?
I can see it.
It looks so cool.
You cannot stop me.
Stop!
Oh, I think she's just, you know, she's a kitten and it's
growing pains, maybe.
You can't see him?
That's so weird.
Maybe I'm gonna take a picture.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I can't.
I take a picture.
It won't show up.
I don't think.
Oh, it does.
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Dang.
Never mind.
That's so weird.
Anyway, he said he wanted them to buy him him and his
powers.
Buy him?
That's how we first heard about him.
Of course we didn't know what he looked like at the time.
And in order to prove these powers of his, he gave them two
predictions.
He foresaw two completely preposterous impossible cases.
The case of a man who would sing national secrets during a
live rock concert broadcast.
who would take the chief commissioner hostage in his own
office.
Those two inmates at the special prison, eh?
We kept tabs on their communications and launched an
investigation.
And then finally, we pinpointed where they were going to
meet tonight and staked it out.
Blue Lady.
That restaurant.
The chicken kitchen.
The manipulator plans on leaving this country tonight.
On a submarine that belongs to the other country in this
deal.
Submarine!
But we haven't been able to find out where it's going to
surface.
It's terrifying to think what would happen if his powers
were to fall into their hands.
That means we just have to...
Wait, we can teleport back to the sub, and we can listen in
on stuff.
I don't know If Blue Country has Blue Lady Doesn't seem so
bad Right Highly unlikely they'd use them for peaceful
purposes And now they have that little girl as a hostage
Camilla We have to stop him before he leaves the country
Sorry Spotless record This spotless record of yours Is it
really that important to you?
Of course, baby.
In some ways, it's more important to me than my life.
Than your life, eh?
After all, it's because of my record that I'm able to get my
hands on all intel.
As head of the Special Investigation Unit.
I'm moving to Blue Lady Country.
Al in favor of moving to Blue Lady Country.
Say I!
I, I, I, I, I, oh, I, me, me, mint, I, Oh, I am...
Yay!
Oh, because of my position.
I get to direct all aspects of the investigation into the
manipulator case.
What confuses me about this, though, is he knew all of this.
But still was going to allow Detective Jowd to be executed?
Oh, but I guess I would...
Because Detective Jowd confessed, right?
And he wanted the spotless record.
Never mind.
Consider a country with Blue Lady also have Blue Shaggy.
All in favor of killing Blue Shaggy.
Say I.
I, I.
Oh, pick me, my lord.
Pick me.
I.
Yeah,
No, not my Oshi.
Your Oshi killed a dog.
What are you talking about?
Your Oshi killed my Oshi.
The manipulator case.
That's why you cared about your record so much.
I mean, I'm not going to lie.
I think the manipulator case is a really big thing to care
about.
Right?
Like, this guy is able to transcend time and space and
people and dimensions.
I think that's a pretty big threat to international
security.
Of course.
Why else, baby?
Yeah, it seems like a pretty big deal.
I just could never believe it, man.
Jal, shooting Alma.
I didn't care that he confessed.
There was definitely something more to the story.
Some secret.
I did everything I could to climb the ladder.
Everything in my power.
And then I finally found the answer.
It took five long years, though.
The manipulator.
He's going to prove that Jowd is innocent.
What incredible determination.
Oh.
Cabanela's determination.
Mint after consulting with scientists.
You're not a byproduct.
Radiation.
But a byproduct.
Electro.
Am I a vampire too?
Oh my god.
There's one thing I just don't understand.
If you were so determined to help Detective Jalad.
Why didn't you help him escape from prison?
Perfect record, perfect record.
That's an easy one, baby.
Escaping from prison is a crime.
I wasn't about to help him commit a crime after spending
five years trying to prove him innocent.
And he himself has to be executed, you know?
As a man of the law, sure that the execution was stopped
legally.
That's why I brought him before the Justice Minister too.
I needed to buy as much time as I possibly could, baby.
Oh, I think they're a little backed up.
Wrong for Rabbit, thank you.
You remember how this game used to be?
Haha, this guy's one step ahead, Tango, and this ghost
leaves two times, but mint.
Now it's about revengeants and aliens and crazy plot twists.
So true.
I love the soundtrack so much.
It's so good.
But there's one little unfortunate result of all of this.
Lynn completely misunderstood your intentions.
Ha!
What's a little misunderstanding?
My baby will come around.
Give it time.
But there are more important things to do with our time
tonight.
Trauma is one of the best tracks.
Is that what this is called?
Trauma!
Thank you, thank you!
Choo!
I came back from a three-mile walk with my dog.
And I po- All I hear is men talking about liquid poop.
I'm sorry!
Kitty funds, thank you!
Thank you, Hyper.
Thank you, thank you.
So that contraption in the basement here, you built that to
try and help Detective Jowd?
That's right.
Jowd and I worked together back when I was with the Force.
I used the reports of his case to try and recreate the
device.
But there was just one part of it that I couldn't reproduce,
no matter how hard I tried.
What is it?
The cupid turning around?
R, R, R, R.
Thank you for the pink don't know.
Thank you so much.
No super chats got it.
Thank you.
Blue cheese.
Thanks for the thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Camilla told Jal- Oh my goodness!
Blue lady is hot.
Hmm?
Shaggy?
Liquid poop is the best part.
No.
How do I say your name?
Is it Ian Tua or is it Lan Tua?
Can't tell if it's an L.
Lowercase L or an uppercase I.
My friend Bob Sakamano had a kitten and I visited him once.
and I was going to return some pants, the cat shat right on
me, really.
I'm sorry, that's not funny.
We're gonna return them.
It's so sad.
Kitten's gonna kitten, I guess.
I guess.
Camilla told Jowd it had something it shouldn't have.
Wait, told Jowd it did something it shouldn't have.
Made an impossible move.
Lantua, like liquid.
Oh, thank you, guys.
Thank you.
They said it's an elf.
Thank you!
I added that part to the device I recreated.
I put in a part that would allow Cupid to rotate, otherwise
the gun wouldn't fire.
So that must mean somebody manipulated Camilla's
contraption.
As a result, we proved to ourselves that the manipulator
actually existed.
Mmm...
Lynn!
Inspector Cabanilla!
Hey, baby.
Oh my god, he's so awesome.
Sorry about that phone call.
I must have sounded like a real villain.
He's so smooth.
I know, my gosh.
I hate it to spoil your image of me.
Of that cool cat inspector you always looked up to.
Is that really the image she had of him?
Inspector Cabanilla.
I'm sorry.
I just heard.
You were chasing after that man all this time.
time to try and help Detective Jowd.
This manipulator is such a dangerous character.
I was hoping you didn't have to be involved.
Oh, I just bit my tongue.
Ow.
So that's why you have me arrested tonight, isn't it?
Like I always say, if somebody's in the way, throw them in
the slammer.
Yikes.
Get out of my way, Lynn.
Mm-hmm.
Rip mint.
Yeah, I've been ripped a long time.
I've been ripped for a while now.
Thanks, though.
Oh, Raiders!
Thank you!
Alien!
I couldn't catch the rest of it, but thank you!
Thanks for the raid!
Hello.
If you have never played Ghost Trick, you're probably going
to be kind of lost.
And if you plan on playing Ghost Trick, Uh, uh, this is
spoilers, I think.
But, uh, thanks for the rating!
Thank you!
Murphy, thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you, thank you.
White on white text, I know.
Tonight.
I'm gonna die in your arms.
Wait.
I think I got it wrong.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Brunk for Robin, thanks for the five gifted.
I really thought we finally had him, but my body gave out on
me right at the critical moment.
It's like a cruel joke.
Whoa, ha, ha, ha.
But a joke is a joke.
You might as well laugh.
Jowd.
The minister called off the execution order.
And while he was at it, he let Detective Jowd go free until
tomorrow morning, too.
That's a pretty extreme while he was at it.
The Chad is here with his massive chin.
Sorry, I took so long to get here.
Yeah, I kept you waiting, huh?
You can leave the rest of me.
There you go again.
You've always been like that.
You make everybody else run around and then you swoop in at
the last second.
Chowd.
He kept his coat!
Five years ago, you left this coat with me just before you
turned yourself in.
I promise to give it back to you one day.
The pigeon!
Pigeon delivery!
What the?
He's still in his prison clothes.
He's in his little onesie.
I've been waiting so long, Detective Jowd.
We are so back.
Look how cool he looks.
I'm waiting for this day to come.
Thanks for not giving up on me, Lin.
Okay, I'm off then.
Good luck, my old friend.
Yeah, prison onesie!
Yeah!
Hypnosis!
Oh, this present you gave me.
It's just what I needed.
Thank you.
Glad you like it.
They don't even look at each other when they send you.
each other off so cool so cool sisal are you there yeah i'm
here you and i have to go find that man i need your help
will you do this with me sure but how we don't know where
the submarine is and the phone line does oh the phone
doesn't work that's news to me they use communication cables
to make their communication cables to make their calls the
doge is right themselves sorry i have my on, you know?
We'll get you hooked up somehow, you'll see.
Could you wait here until we do?
Please?
Okay, fine.
I'm counting on you.
This true self you're looking for.
I bet you'll find it soon.
Aw.
Alright, I'm leaving, Inspector Cabanella.
It's almost on.
I'm not who I thought I was.
I'm actually further from knowing who I am than ever.
But now I don't feel so alone.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, they didn't disconnect, they're right.
Just got major snoss a lot.
Snoss a lot vibes.
Why do you think I like Cicil and Inspector Cabanela?
Snoss a lot works though.
Snodicon?
Snodicon for these two is Snoss a lot for Inspector Cabanela
and Cicil.
I mistype.
of us for his or her own reasons is looking for the truth.
Together, I think we can shed light on these mysteries and
drive away the darkness.
But it's almost dawn.
This one's a long chapter.
Two hours.
Wow.
We're gonna be in it tonight, you guys.
Maybe I should have started sooner.
This is my formal apology for thinking Cabanilla is one of
the blue guys last stream.
He's now just below missile and coolness.
I agree.
I agree, David.
but it's just black.
There's nothing...
Oh, wait, I see what it is.
I think.
It's, um...
I think it's the sidebars.
Oh, neat!
Oh!
Ghost trick!
Langering death.
Did you guys like the thumbnail?
I even, like, manipulated my body so that...
so that it even matched the way the thumbnail looked in the,
or the portrait in the game.
Oh, the submarine.
Oh, Cecil!
Okay, saving.
Manipulator?
Oh, my gosh.
Maybe I do have the ghost trick powers.
Continue playing.
Go men for backseating.
Cats, but IBD is sometimes as easy as Prudhubu.
I'll forget to vet.
IBD worsens not improves for everyone with this issue.
You know what?
I'm not going to lie.
When I got her, I thought that when she had her first
pooping episode, I was like, I wonder if she has IBS.
I don't know what IBD is, but I'll look into it.
And don't apologize for...
for trying to help.
I really appreciate it.
Your inflammatory bowel disease.
I wonder, is that it?
Irritable boob syndrome?
No!
Is she throwing up?
No, not at all.
No throwing up.
Oh, she threw up once.
The first time I got her, but I think that was because she
was stressed.
Call it hot girl tummy problems.
All hot girls have IBS.
It's because God had to nerf them a little bit.
They had to have IBS because they're too hot.
I'd be shit in IBS.
All hot girls have IBS.
I'm a hot girl.
Woo!
Sasaki syndrome.
And what do you know?
He's hot.
There has to be something wrong with you.
You can't just be hot and normal, okay?
What a nerve.
I don't have IVS.
Lynn kept her promise about getting me hooked up.
About two hours before dawn, the phone rang.
Two hours?
That's it.
Oh gosh.
Ring-a-ling-a-ling!
Ring-a- Sorry.
I like almost hiccuped.
This is Jowd.
Cicil, are you listening?
We need your powers.
No time to talk.
We'll be waiting for you.
Okay.
Is that why Johnny's hot?
Yes.
Look at him.
What is this look on the doctor?
What is this look on his face?
Look at it.
What is this look on your face?
Oh, are you looking at me?
Well, you better get going.
He's talking to me.
This long night is drawing to an end.
Yeah, it looks like it.
Thank you for all your help tonight.
I'm the one who should be thanking you.
The bird bowed at me.
At the other end of the phone line, I'm finally going to
find all my answers.
I'd better go.
Fourth wall break.
He looked directly at my soul.
I mean, I am a soul.
That's why I know.
So that's why you jeans oh fiber, fiber, what are you
talking about?
What are you talking about, Misfits?
A single telephone line connects me and the other sisal.
But that single line spreads out like a spider's web to
instare the fates of many people.
How'd they get in?
When I just reached the center of the web.
Whoa!
Fiber, fiber, fiber, fiber, fiber, fiber.
Eat more fiber.
Welcome to the Yonoa.
Detective Jowd.
Oh!
How did he get in here?
How did you get in here?
Did you swim here?
Detective!
My detective sense must have gotten rusty.
I didn't even sense your presence here in the dark.
He's just that good.
That's because I switched the power to my mask off,
Detective Jowd.
I used your phone.
Hope you don't mind.
B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-Bam.
You think he slaps asses like that machine?
Hey, God!
Never thought you'd track us here, especially seeing as you
are a death row window.
mate.
And I'm equally surprised about your choice of
transportation.
A submarine, eh?
No, he's a gentleman.
But how did you find us, my man?
Not even the police knew where the Yonoa was going to
surface.
Confounded?
Oh, it surfaced!
We detectives have a little saying.
If there's something you want to know about a case, ask the
criminals.
When did he...
The bullet the man in red was shot with had a radio
transmitter in it.
What?
I have a little something for you.
And it's the pocket watch.
Is it actually like a...
Oh my god, it's a dragon ball scouter.
Oh my god!
Cabanella has given me some pretty weird presence in the
past.
But they always prove useful.
This one was a radio receiver made to look like a pocket
watch.
Birkenstel!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Hmm, yes, Inspector Cabanella.
I hear he's an excellent investigator.
By the way, where is that man in red?
I know he's on this submarine somewhere.
That's an Ocelot move for real.
Oh, ah, sisal you mean?
I've been here the whole time.
Oh my god, that's so funny.
You can relax.
That's nothing but his shell.
YouTube dying tonight.
Uh-oh, I hope everything's okay.
His shell, eh?
His spirit isn't here right now.
Most likely right about now.
controlling your daughter.
Please, I beg you, let my daughter go.
If you need a hostage, take me.
Just please, let her go.
Bah.
There's something our nation needs.
Cicel has it.
That's all we care about, my man.
Nothing else matters.
However, it would appear.
Cicel has underestimated us.
He's left behind his precious bargaining chip here.
bargaining chip.
Oh, us!
Oh, just kidding.
It's me.
I'm the... I thought he was gonna go and, like, suck me
down.
Our nation has already researched it.
This product that Cicil has to offer.
The meteor.
The source of his powers.
Bip, bip, bip, bip.
Slap.
Whoa, that's a hunk of chunk.
Wowee!
Oh!
It's ours now, or it's theirs, I guess.
What?
What in the world was that?
The Temsic fragment.
It gives spirits special powers.
And now our deal with Cicil is concluded, as far as we're
concerned.
What are you talking about?
What a mistake to make.
Right, at the most crucial moment.
Now then, Detective Jowd!
Farewell.
Slap!
Oh!
Uh...
What?
What in the world?
The whole room just vanished!
Detective Jowd!
Where did he go?
Where?
Oh, because the table moved, the telephone went down there?
Oh gosh, what's going on?
Why is there a basketball?
What now?
I think I heard an explosion somewhere.
Oh, that means we'll probably have to switch things with
a...
With missile again.
In any case, Lynn and the little lady should be here
somewhere.
I smell danger.
I'd better find them.
And fast!
Trigger.
Who is this?
So you're here, huh?
It's Missou!
Woo!
Yes, I think you and I remember who you are by now.
It's Minto!
What do you suppose that shock was a minute ago?
I have no idea, of course!
I'm just a little sheltered apartment dog!
What with my memory, loss of memory?
I can't say much, I'm much better.
Anyway, let's hurry up and go save Miss Lin and Miss
Camilla.
Do you think that trusty nose of yours can sniff them out?
It's Mintolo!
I'm sorry to say I don't think it can.
Did I even bother to ask?
But you do have the power to swap objects.
So let's find that lady detective and that little lady
together.
I got it!
Ringling!
Are those missiles?
I think, uh, are those missiles, missile?
I'm gonna put mint on my shower speakers.
Have a nice shower!
The telephone is ringing.
Wow!
It's Miss Camilla, I just know it!
My trusty nose is practically screaming it at me!
I think you'd call that more of a hunch.
Anyway, let's get to the phone before it stops ringing.
Those are torpedoes.
I guess you're right.
You bet.
Trick time.
Let's see.
Oh, that's where Missile is.
I can't reach anywhere else, so we're gonna...
We're gonna...
Num, num, num.
What is this?
Emergency light.
Can Missile...
Oh, hello!
Hello, Miss Camilla!
Hello!
I don't think he can pick up the phone.
It's no use!
This black hello just doesn't like me!
What?
Just create a path for me, Missal.
I'll come right over.
Okay.
What do I need to switch?
No.
I could switch the aversion lights but it doesn't really do
much maybe if i switch oh okay he's so cute i know it's just
this precious little guy and switch switcheroo there we go
oh oh oh oh i think i just heard another the distance.
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Cicel, look!
That black hello, it came off the hook!
Uh-oh, I better answer it fast!
Meow, meow, meow!
Easy.
Hello!
Is anybody there?
It's her, the little lady.
It's Cicel, where are you?
Somebody please answer!
I guess she can't hear my voice.
You too, huh?
Oh, good.
I thought she was ignoring me.
Somebody help me.
Lin...
Uh-oh.
It's been a while since Lin's died.
She said, Lin.
Miss Lin!
We'd better hurry.
Let's go, Sissel.
Go there.
It's been a real long time since Lin's died.
Oh, wait, no.
She's not dead.
Oh, wait a second.
Maybe she is dead.
Her body is not dead.
yellow though
but she's kind of like I thought she was just like leaning
over like the staircase but um uh oh are we gonna have like
Titanic our way out of here oh no
it's no use nobody's answering oh Camilla Miss Miss Camilla
and Miss Miss Lynn!
Oh poor Miss Lynn!
Yeah, she can't seem to catch a break.
Looks like another tragedy has happened.
Sorry to keep you waiting a little.
Little lady.
Sissy, I knew you'd come.
Miss Camilla!
And Missle too!
I'm so glad to see you're all right.
All right.
Well, I wouldn't say I'm all right exactly.
Hey, wait a minute.
Missile, your voice.
I think I remember hearing it somewhere before.
What?
My voice?
That's right.
Camilla has a core now, so that means she did hear Missile's
voice before when he saved her that time.
Just that was you, wasn't it, Missile?
You're the one who saved me in the park tonight.
Thank you.
Miss Camilla, I'm so glad I was born your little doggy.
think about my Oshis.
I'm so glad I was born to die to become your own, to become
a fan of you.
Hey, Missa, could you stay here and watch over your mistress
for a while?
Huh?
But don't you need my powers?
I'll see what I can do on my own for a while.
After all, you're the only one who can protect her.
Okay, I'll do it!
I love I love my soul.
I wonder what happened this time.
I better talk to the little lady more.
I wonder if she got electrocuted from the water.
I'd better do something about the detective lady.
Oh, oh, uh, turn it.
Okay.
I'm happy you died to become my Yoshi Did you have to censor
it because YouTube I appreciate it
I'm glad I died too then Oh sisal you're here
Lynn what in the world happened here I don't know I just
sort of blacked out all of a sudden I know I was dead!
Yeah, I guess you wouldn't know in that case.
You guys...
I think I have to go to the little ghosties room.
I think I have to go to the ghosties room.
I can't believe in the two and a half hours I've left the
stream three times.
That's insane.
That never happens.
I won't allow you.
Please!
I prefer you dead ghost.
That's because I have two drinks.
Okay, you can listen to this bop and soundtrack and I'll be
right back.
I'm sorry, I just have to pee.
I have to expel the ectoplasm.
Actually, that's not a good way to say that.
You know what?
Oh my god, when I opened the door, when I opened the door to
leave, um Paz came like running at me and she was like She
kept chirping at me And then she was following me And I fed
her I fed her When I went to go get the water earlier So So
I know she wasn't hungry I think she was like Lethargic all
day Or it's like she slept all day Because I had to give her
a bath earlier And I think it made her really tired I think
I gave her a bath earlier From the poop And She slept all
day, she was just sad about it And now she's all like happy
She even followed me into the bathroom One thing I really
love about her One thing that I think is the cutest thing
about her Is she's a plopper Like she doesn't just like lay
down normally She just like she goes like Plop She's so cute
So like She even followed me into the bathroom And was just
like La la la Hello Hello Hello mom And then she just
plopped on the ground.
She's so cute.
Does she spread out?
Yes, she does.
She bananas.
She turns into a banana.
She's a plopper in more ways than one.
I hate that.
I hate that so much.
She's really sweet.
I really love her.
I do.
I hope she's okay.
It makes stresses me out.
Me wondering if she's...
good you know what how did i there we go okay there we go
okay let's get back to the game let's get back to that game
bye bye bye bye yeah i guess you wouldn't know in that case
i don't know what we're talking about oh uh about how she
died that's right and where's detective jowd is he all right
i don't know huh the room he was in just disappeared all of
a sudden So cute.
Yeah.
Now it's all making even less sense than before.
Oh, give me one second.
Let me check something on my phone.
Uh, what is, wait.
Oh, never mind, okay.
I'm good, I'm good.
Everything okay?
Yep, all good.
After we left the super's office, we followed after the man
in red.
We tracked him with that radio transmitter and Spectre
Calvonella fired into him with the bullet.
The man in red took a boat out to sea from a small harbor on
the edge of town.
Detective Jowd and I managed to secretly stow away on his
boat.
And then we sneaked onto the submarine with him when it
surfaced.
Before long, the submarine dove back down again.
Oh, so that's how.
Okay, I was like, how did you...
Okay, thank you for the...
Thank you for the explanation of how he got down there under
the water.
Under the sea.
Detective Jowden and I decided to split up.
He would take care of the telephone line and I would look
for Camilla.
I found Camilla hiding here in the engine room.
She had escaped and run away here.
Do, do, do, do, do.
Babe.
Wow, that's quite an adventure.
What happened next?
I don't know.
Huh?
There was a flash of white all of a sudden.
Next thing I know I was dead!
Okay, she definitely got electrocuted, I think.
Oh boy, it sounds like it'd be quicker for me to see for
myself.
Oh, time to rewind.
Maybe from the water.
Yes, you know.
Camilla, are you okay?
Wow!
Oh, my God.
Camilla?
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
She's getting manipulated!
Ah.
Hello, Lynn.
Or is it detective now?
It's been 10 years since we last met.
Are you...
Are you really that man from the park 10 years?
ago well well I see there's no need to introduce myself give
Camilla back she has nothing to do with any of this afraid I
can't do that this is my last chance look at the sass the
hand on the hip the phone is ringing it's not for me nobody
ever calls the dead.
Yo!
Single-handedly!
The fact that you're here means that my revenge plan has
failed.
Revenge plan?
It didn't happen tonight, did it?
His execution.
Well, knowing him, they have expected as much.
That's why I was waiting here like this.
him to show up.
Ta-da!
Wouldn't it be just what he wanted to be executed by his own
daughter?
I heard about 10 years ago.
Oh, wait, wait.
I feel sorry about what happened to you.
But revenge?
Hmm.
Nobody could possibly know what I've...
Oh!
What in the world?
An explosion?
Uh-oh.
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Have I been had?
Look out!
Oh.
Revenge, huh?
That's a feeling I just can't understand.
Of course not.
You're not him.
She's right.
I'm not him, am I?
He was going to shoot Detective Jowd.
That's Camilla, when he came to rescue her.
It's just too horrible.
Anyway, let's bring you back to life again.
He didn't have to add the again part.
Okay.
How do we stop this?
How?
Trick time.
How do we stop this?
So let's see.
The cause of death this time was the mysterious experience.
explosion
You're pretty up for a dead woman
You know how detectives love a good mystery.
It's like a shot of vitamins And what do you mean for a dead
woman?
Do you guys think that I'm energetic for being so dead?
I guess we should look and look for a way to stop that
explosion.
Okay, let's do this thing finding clues is like a dose of
minerals to a detective quite very yeah you're quite lively
I'm afraid with my memory loss I have no idea what vitamins
or minerals rocks fossils rocks rocks and minerals are you
okay let's see what do we have oh oh yes this whole this
whole scenario let's see oh i can't get to anywhere i am
trapped we have to wait for her to move the gun
i think yeah we still can't do anything wait can i switch to
no i can't switch to um But also, if I can't switch the...
I wouldn't be able to switch things anyway, I think, because
the ghost...
Cicil would notice.
No one calls for the dead.
Oh!
And here we go.
Trick time!
Wait, but who's calling?
I can't get the line to work.
That's funny.
I thought I could use the phone in the past if somebody was
calling.
Yeah!
What are you talking about?
The receiver has to be off the hook first, silly.
Oh.
Well, don't look at me.
I can't do it.
I don't have any hands or feet right now.
Somebody, please answer the phone.
If you want something done, you have to do it yourself.
Okay.
Let's go up here.
This is an emergency light.
What does turning this do?
Mm-hmm.
Uh-huh.
This is the phone.
Oh, what about turning this, too?
Let's turn this.
Turn, turn, turn.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
That's what that did.
Anyway, somehow managed to knock down the receiver.
That, I'm kind of concerned about the condition of this
submarine.
Somehow managed.
Who's to say that's not how I planned it?
Come on, hurry.
Now's your chance to get on the phone.
It might be Detective Jowd.
She's right.
I'd better check it out.
Using the new episode of the podcast to power me through
finding a different job.
Funny that a ghost is helping me quit the job of Woods Gnome
encouraged me to pass the interview.
I mean...
Um...
You know what?
I think the Woods Gnome...
Probably didn't know what they were talking about.
And you know what?
Just like I came back, there were changes.
You can do changes too.
You know?
Yeah.
Quit your job.
And I'll encourage you for the next one.
Hello.
Anybody there?
If anybody's still there, get yourself here on the double.
We're about to head out.
you answer anyway come on if you're coming we're leaving oh
i guess i better go there because they're leaving get gnomed
silly hmm so i have to delay them leaving because that's the
explosion so it might be true what they say that there are
restless ghosts on board whoa creepy Okay, we're back here.
That does it.
I promise to turn over a new leaf, Mom.
Wait, don't leave!
Who is he calling restless ghosts?
Yeah!
Who is he calling restless...
Who is he calling restless ghosts?
Hmm.
Well, it's true neither of us is really resting in peace.
Anyway.
Looks like the sub just lost one of its crew.
I guess that means the fate of this sub has changed
slightly.
Okay, nice.
Cicil has underestimated us.
He's left behind his precious bargaining chip here.
Ah, okay, this is when they take the stone.
Okay, there goes the phone.
Detective Jowd.
What's going on there?
I saw this little deal go down once before.
In just a moment, the man in red is about to get his Temsik
fragment.
fragment taken away okay so do I have to go up there what's
happening they decided to conclude the deal without the
other party present they're just going to go ahead and steal
the Temsic fragment but that's that's cheating I think we
have more important things to think about right now Where's
the Temsic fragment going to go?
True, true, true.
Uh...
If I open this...
Boink!
Oh!
Uh...
Wait, um...
Okay, hold on.
Open...
And go!
Now!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Wait, wait, I'm gonna be stuck, though.
What's this valve do?
Eep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep,
peep, peep, peep, peep.
Oh, oh, there it goes, there it goes, there it goes.
And up, is it easy?
Oh my god.
Why are there so many men in the submarine?
The Temsic fragment.
The objective has been achieved.
Now we detach the control room as planned.
Yes, sir.
Farewell, sir.
Yeah, it's like a clown car for real.
clown sub.
Sissel, what just happened?
The whole room just disappeared with Detective Jowd in it.
Don't worry, Lin.
I bet Detective Jowd can take care of himself.
The main thing right now is rescuing you and the little
lady.
I can't believe this is happening.
Now then, I'd better hurry along before Sissel discovers
what he's lost and comes after me.
The Yanoa will be his coffin.
Oh!
May it lie buried here in the deep sea.
Farewell, sisal.
There he goes.
Oh, and that's why the water starts to rise too.
I think?
These poor guys.
Oh!
There he goes.
Taking off.
Hmm.
Oh, so that's the cause of that giant explosion.
I think we probably gotta get the little handle thing down
there, right?
What is?
Don't tell me that's another thing you've forgotten.
The torpedo!
It's like, well, you've heard of a missile before, haven't
you?
Yeah, the dog.
But a different missile comes more readily to mind.
It looks like he plans to sink the submarine with that
thing.
just not let it rise to the surface.
All you have to do is just let it sit at the bottom, right?
This is not good.
We have to do something before that torpedo is fired!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Uh...
Lower!
It won't budge.
Maybe it's broken.
Oh, well, I guess I don't have to lower it right now.
And even if I had to move it, I could probably get Lynn to
do it for me.
Oh, what are you talking about?
What about this one?
Nothing's happening.
You're done goofed?
Uh-oh.
Sure seems like it should do something.
Maybe it's just some kind of ornament.
We can't let it launch.
I think it's launched.
What can we do?
Let's just get to the torpedo as fast as we can.
Maybe we can find a way to stop it somehow.
Somehow?
A true detective never gives up.
We certainly can't just ignore it.
Oh, I think we've lost our chance.
What was my chance?
Was it with the rock?
Or...
Maybe when I launch this up, I attach myself to the rock?
I guess
we'll just see what happens.
It's gonna launch!
There's no use.
There's nothing we can do from here.
Okay.
Meaum!
Trick time.
Oh.
There goes the missile.
Now there's really nothing we can do.
If only our missile was here right now.
And bet he'd try to take it head on for us.
Yeah, I bet he would.
Looks like we better rethink this whole thing.
Okay, from the fate change.
There goes missile, but not the dog.
I think I have to attach myself to...
The rock.
Right?
When it gets...
Hold on.
Oh, I can't see it.
Okay, I wanted to see if I could...
Okay.
Grab the rock!
Eat it up!
Okay.
Now!
Uh...
I wonder...
Open!
I wonder if I'm timing this.
Correctly.
I don't think I did.
Okay, one more.
One more.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Uh...
You can wait in the light.
Oh, that's right!
You guys are so smart.
Wait!
No!
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
I missed my chance!
Oh!
Nice!
Never mind.
I didn't miss my chance.
Wait, if I'm here...
Oh, I'm in the capsule.
Okay, okay, okay.
La la la.
Whew, that was so close.
Clutch, man.
Clutch.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
La la la la.
From the capsule, what can I do?
Hmm.
You caught the after image?
I'm just that good.
That's the cause.
Baa, baa, baa, baa, baa, baa.
Uh-oh.
Do something!
Is it the lever?
Perhaps it is?
Lower the lever.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Baa, baa, baa, baa, baa.
okay I'm inside wait that's not letting me do anything else
there's no time it's gonna launch we can still find a way to
stop it how even if the torpedo does launch we just have to
stop it from detonating right there's still something we can
do okay I hope why was the I hope at the end of the strong
at the end the strongest part of that sentence here goes oh
my god it Why is there a mouse in here?
Why is there a mouse in the torpedo?
How did you get in here?
I came along for the ride without giving it too much
thought.
Well, was this really the best move?
I think so.
We just have to keep it from going off, right?
Okay, mouse.
I'm sure this poor little rat will thank us too.
Sorry, I kept saying mouse.
a rat!
How in the world did it get in there?
Okay.
This game hates rats.
This game is...
Oh, I think these outside parts are supposed to be weights
of some sort.
Spending black things, right?
Apparently their spinning helps the torpedo maintain its
balance.
They must be pretty heavy.
I wonder if we can use these weights to our advantage
somehow.
Stop!
Uh...
operate operate okay let's examine the detonator this is
probably the detonator don't press it the torpedo will
explode uh oh better be careful but you know there should be
a safety device around here somewhere safety device huh that
sounds promising we have to put the safety on before this
thing blows up wait What's the audio or the dialogue here?
Press it.
Do you know how a torpedo works?
No, I can't say I do.
Wow, detectives sure know a lot.
I saw it explained once in a book.
On impact, the fuse in the...
Okay, someone tell me if this is accurate.
I'm so curious.
On impact, the fuse in the tip is depressed.
Uh-huh.
That, in turn, sets off the detonator.
Whoa.
The detonator, huh?
That must be the red button.
Kind of not a...
Wait, so there's like a tiny little red button inside a
torpedo?
Oh, this sounds so silly, though.
There it is, for real?
Probably won't be a button.
IRL torpedoes have rats in them, too.
Wow!
Some more of like an igniter.
Okay, that makes more sense.
So how do we stop it?
I didn't explain anything about that in the book.
Detectives sure know a lot.
Or not.
Okay.
Let's operate the joint.
Oh!
Oh my god.
This looks like just the thing.
If we clamp this thing on the fuse, it should keep it from
moving.
So what does that mean exactly?
It means we might be able to...
to stop the torpedo from exploding with this.
I have to admit, I don't understand all the details.
But I do want to give it a try.
Before we can do that, looks like we have to get something
out of the way first, huh?
Um, little rat.
Little rat.
Okay.
I think if we stop it in a certain way, it will fling the
rat.
He'll be either like, woo!
Or he'll be like, woo!
You know?
Let's try stopping this one.
Oh god.
Oh god!
Oh god, oh god.
Oh god, maybe I was wrong.
What?
How do I get you out of here?
Stop!
When I stop one...
Wait.
When I stop one, the other one starts.
Oh, wait a second.
Oh!
Oh, I had to time it.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my God.
We've dumped the little creature off.
Okay.
Those weights were heavy enough to turn the whole torpedo
over.
I knew that was going to happen.
Now for that safety device.
Right.
Oh, my God.
Eum.
Operate.
There.
We clamped the safety device on.
I totally knew that was gonna happen I should keep this
torpedo from exploding But there's just one problem Problem?
What's that?
The torpedo is still going to impact We can't do anything
about that Uh-oh Oh Sasuga Tensai Minto Thank you Oh but it
didn't The explosion didn't happen so all the stuff didn't
come.
It didn't, like, come toppling down the ceiling and stuff.
It looks like the torpedo still hit the sub.
But it looks like the submarine is still...
Okay!
This changes everybody's fate, including the little rats.
Cicel, we did it!
Fate averted.
What's the matter?
You still look unhappy.
Crash is better than an explosion, exactly.
We stopped the torpedo from blowing up.
But we still opened up a gaping hole in the submarine.
You're right.
I guess...
I guess that's just what missiles do.
They're unstoppable!
Am I hearing things?
Anyway.
I guess we better get back to the present as quickly as we
can.
Right.
I'm worried about Camilla.
I think our best boy is talking.
Okay.
I think our best boy is hanging about.
We managed to stop death for now, but it hasn't disappeared
altogether.
It's now slowly but surely filling the room.
Oh, Titanic scary!
Uh-oh.
Water is seeping in through the hole where the torpedo hit!
I have to step out.
Here's an early congrats on reaching the end, Mint.
It was so fun to watch.
Poopy!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
We've got to get them out of here.
I'd better go meet up with Lynn.
Trick drive.
I like this soundtrack too.
It's so cool.
Wheel.
Oh, what's this one doing?
Starter.
Transformer.
Medium fan.
I guess start whatever we're starting.
Oh!
The lights went out, but this machine apparently still
works.
The ride only gets crazier from here?
Unfortunately, I guess it won't run for very long.
How much crazier can it get?
Maybe I can use its movements to help me create a path.
I'd better hurry over to Lin.
It's not safe to stay here.
I just don't have the power to stop that water from coming
in.
Wait, what did I change?
really change anything.
I don't think at least.
Oh!
That thing right there.
Let's...
Oh, uh...
Okay, can't do anything with the fans.
But I can...
Do this.
Oh.
A little bit.
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Wait, what can I do with this piston?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oh, it lifted up.
Oh, I thought I was trapped for a second for real.
Oh my gosh.
She cooking.
Camilla.
Lynn!
Camilla, you're awake!
How do you feel?
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry I pointed that gun at you.
Wait, so she remembers it.
Camilla's been the manipulator this whole time.
Well, how do you remember that, huh, Camilla?
Don't worry about that.
That wasn't you.
Miss Camilla!
Oh, Missal, you're here.
Oh, poor Miss Camilla.
Miss Lynn, what should we do?
We have to get out of here before any more water comes in.
Cicil should be along any second.
I knew Cicil would come.
And Missy is here too.
I'm so happy everybody's going to be with me now.
Oh, dies.
Uh-oh.
God, I love that dog.
Me too.
I'll get you out of here.
If it's the last thing I do...
Don't say that, Lynn, because it might very well be...
I think I'm going to cry.
Or whimper, as the case may be.
I better send a signal to Lynn that I'm here.
Before it's too late.
Beep.
It's me.
Look at that flashlight.
It's Cicel.
He's here.
That was a quick death flag.
Yeah, it was.
What if there's like a...
Can you imagine?
What if there's like a thing...
A puzzle that we can't...
Solve at some point.
That scares me.
What if, like, Lynn dies and we try to solve the puzzle and
she's like, There's no helping it.
It just has to be this way.
No, I don't want that to happen.
I'm glad you're here, Sissel.
Sorry for the wait.
It looks like this room is going to fill up with water fast.
We'd better get out that door as quick as we can.
We won't be getting out that door, I'm afraid.
The water pressure is too great already.
I can't open it.
what what does water pressure mean
think of it as the force of the water holding the door
closed sisal is so dumb i love this guy the water level
keeps getting higher and higher in here so the only way out
of here is up huh exactly okay got it let's look for a path
that goes up which i see one already right there oh you
missed it oh right there Look at that ladder.
I wonder if we can get it down somehow.
Good idea.
Let's try it.
What is water?
Oh, and by the way...
I can't swim.
Neither can Camilla.
Oh my god.
Don't you have any good news for me?
Let me think about it.
In the meantime, could you hurry, please?
Okay, I'm assuming...
I'm assuming...
I'm assuming this is time then.
What does this do?
Oh.
Uh...
Handle, turn the handle!
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
Let's see.
Switch lower.
Nice.
You did it, Sissel.
Fake Talibar.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Where's Raiden when you need him?
I know, right?
Listen to the sound of my heartbeat.
Or lack thereof.
Okay, we're here.
Nice.
What was that?
It looks like water seeping in isn't the only thing we have
to worry about.
And I hope you can manage to avoid drowning for two cute
girls.
Leave it to me!
Uh-oh.
No, our flashlight!
The flashlight doesn't work anymore!
Hey, don't get mad at me.
Maybe the contacts are bad or something.
Hey, I know, you can fix it with your powers!
I...
Now that's just taking things too far.
okay wait can I actually turn it on oh it actually worked
did you used to be an electrician in your past life or
something that's a cruel question considering the
circumstances now all we have to do is get to that door and
we're safe oh oh oh Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's actually the Titanic.
Oh my god.
Listen to the sound of the no posters on my wall.
What does that mean?
What happened now?
Looks like the submarine decided to rear up on its hind
legs.
I can't believe we're still okay after that fall.
Oh, I mean, speak for yourself, but Camilla right there, she
looks like...
She doesn't look like she's doing so well.
Either we're really lucky or we're dead and we just haven't
realized it yet.
Come on now, as if the latter could be true.
Uh, Camilla!
Oh, no way.
Oh, now!
Oh, The water sure is rising fast!
Something's rising and it isn't the shield hero.
Come on!
Oh my god.
You'll just have to go up!
Up to the top!
But Kamua!
Let's see how I can help with my ghost tricks.
What are we gonna do with her?
I think I see a familiar flame over there.
Oh, oh.
Missa!
Cicel, there you are!
How's it going?
it going I'd say it was going pretty badly someday it'll be
the shield hero like you guys what's rising is the water
it's the water that's rising what else would I mean it's the
water see you do understand how dangerous the situation is
don't you oh the water of course after all just ask anybody
who knows me about how much I hate taking a bath.
Usually dogs like baths, though.
Have you guys ever met a dog that doesn't like a bath?
Maybe he's been in danger of drowning before himself.
Okay.
Ready to create a path for these ladies?
Of course!
Alright.
Trick time.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Uh...
No, uh, I guess swap, sure.
Oh, wait.
Uh, let's see.
Where can we go to?
What can we...
Oh, my goodness.
Wow, there's a lot of stuff here.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, there's so much stuff here.
Oh, I'm feeling a little overwhelmed with this one.
Oh, my God.
And we have to get all the way to the top, right?
Here!
Okay.
Uh...
Uh, remember that the water is rising.
Yes, yes.
But they can't swim.
Okay.
And what can we do?
Nothing.
Maybe we have to switch it with a bigger wheel.
Actually, I don't think that's possible.
Oh.
Why do we switch first?
My brain is already earning these are the same shape what do
you mean they can't what if I swap these does it do anything
I don't think so I'm just just switching things to switch
them I can't believe it's been almost two months since your
return my brain rotting mind imagine you coming out of a
foggy haunted forest stands up like hey Hachi when he came
out of the red smoke in Tekken 7.
That's pretty epic entrance, I'd say.
Thank you.
I need to let time move to see some changes.
Oh.
The water's rising.
Oh my god, that's...
I have to find a way for Lin to get up to the top.
A woman who can't swim in an ambitious woman.
They both head for the top.
Aether drop.
Thanks for joining membership.
To do that, I need to create some kind of footholds for her.
A woman who can't swim and a sensible woman.
They both keep their feet on the ground.
Okay.
Well, so much for waiting for...
So much for waiting.
Okay.
I'm going ghost.
What?
What the...
I don't even know what to switch at all.
Don't forget Cicel.
Yeah, but he can't go anywhere right now.
Oh wait, yes again!
What the hell?
Am I stupid?
Am I dumb?
Don't answer that.
So she was looking at the wheel with the flashlight, wasn't
she?
I feel like I need to put like Let me talk for hints Go up
is easier said than done when I'm holding Camilla I know
we're gonna try and create a path for you somehow The water
just keeps on rising Please hurry Oh and by the way did I
ever tell you You can't swim Neither can Camilla Oops I
already said that didn't I Okay well good luck Okay Oh,
my brain...
Wait, operate.
Okay.
Oh.
These pistons sticking out right in front of me.
It's almost like they're taunting me.
Maybe it's a challenge.
It might be just that.
Think you can climb them?
Hmm.
If I wasn't holding Camilla, I could probably do it easily.
Sizzle!
You're not telling Miss Linda.
to leave poor Miss Camilla behind.
Are you?
Could you be quiet for a minute?
Sizzle?
Shut the hell up.
These pistons sure do look like they could be used to our
advantage.
This piston...
They're silently pressuring me to climb them.
I doubt they're doing that, Miss Lynn.
It looks like...
It looks like how much the pistons thrust out is related to
how large the fan...
Ah!
My arms are full, but my legs are free.
If you could just move these pistons, so they're a little
easier to climb, I think I could do it.
We need the three different size of fans.
No, no!
We had the small one here.
Oops.
I think the small one needs to go here.
But we need the large fan.
Okay.
Wait, okay, let's switch the large fan first down here.
No, no, no.
Switch.
Okay, medium fan...
Medium fan, fine.
And then here...
And small fan.
There we go.
Okay.
Uh...
ZR, ZR, ZR, ZR, ZR, ZR, ZR
There we go!
How about that?
Wow, this is great!
You made a staircase for me!
You better hurry!
I don't think the water is gonna wait for you!
Okay, yep.
Let's go!
Let's climb!
Nice job, Minto!
Thank you!
I think I was trying to see everything all at once.
But now that I'm seeing that it's done in part, it's not so
bad, you know?
Okay, here she has to avoid the steam.
Yeah, I knew that was gonna hurt her.
Now the steam is getting out.
Yeah, okay, I think for this one, we have to see, we have to
switch the ones that are pointed down and the ones that are
pointed up, you know?
It's too hot to get through.
And there's no way to get around either.
Think you can do something?
Of course we can!
We have to.
Trick time.
Oh, let's get you up there.
Okay.
Like, for example, these two can switch.
Now if they switch, see?
Oh, but that one's pointed.
Ah, that one is flowing both ways.
If I swap the pipes, it changes how the steam comes out.
Because the cracks in each pipe are different.
Yes, so each pipe sprays out the scenes in a different way.
I bet that will come in handy But Two of them Two of them
wait are there any other ones?
That they can swap with doesn't seem like it wait down No,
that's the balancer
Hmm Whoa!
Okay, so they have different degrees too.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, hold on!
I have to see!
Oh my gosh.
Here comes the water!
I wish I could drink it up for you.
No, Missal, it's too salty!
I think the more relevant point is that he's dead so we
can't drink it.
Just do something about the steam.
Leave it to me!
Oh, let's try getting Sisal to...
um maybe the maybe the what's it called oh no wait i'm stuck
wait i'm stuck ah oh if i operate this
can i get back up there oh my god i'm stuck oh there we go
okay nice nice nice
okay okay oh my gosh wait i'm still stuck there we go okay i
think we can turn this wheel and that will adjust how some
of the seam works oh nice nice nice but
we need okay we need this one to switch with this one
because this one has the most heavy amount of oh wait they
both have a heavy amount of oh wait wait wait oh i did it
How does that look?
It looks great.
All that horrible steam is cleared out of the way.
It's not far now.
Let's try and move forward.
You swapped perfectly.
First try.
Yeah.
I thought I might have to swap one other one, but nice.
Look up there if I can just make it to that door.
We can escape.
Now, how in the world am I going to get up there?
Don't yell at me.
If you want to yell, you can yell at me.
Oh my god, no, nobody shouldn't yell at you, Missal.
You should play the lottery mint?
With my luck?
No way.
Missal, how can I yell at you when you're so sweet about it?
Oh, I think you just did.
Let's look for something...
To pull Miss Lynn up with.
Something to whisk Miss Lynn up and glide her ever so gently
to the top with.
Hey, are you being sarcastic?
Alright.
No, no.
Let's see what we got here.
A distributing panel.
A switch, a fuse box.
A wheel.
The wheel works for...
Wait, the switch works for this, uh, for, for this ladder.
So what does this wheel do?
Hmm.
Uh, oh, oh, I'm going ghost.
Okay, let's see.
The switch.
Um, how can I get over there?
Hmm.
Because I think the wheel is what does it.
How can I get over there?
Mmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm.
Emergency light pipe.
Uh...
Oh wait, actually, let's get you out of there.
Let's get to the fuse box and see if there's something we
can do here.
Oh!
Open.
Open, Sesame!
Okay, ghost.
Now we can open the door.
If I can get this door open, Lynn can escape.
I can't budge it.
It must be stuck or something.
I guess we'll have to wait for Lynn to use her miraculous
power.
Well, first we have to get up there.
Oh, we can move the hook.
Easy.
Never mind, I was overthinking either.
Now this is what I'm talking about.
Okay, nice.
Okay, raise away!
Whoa!
Alrighty.
Okay, come on, Lynn.
Use your super strength.
Girl, boss, your way through the door.
Sorry, I can't do it.
Open it, hurry!
Is that any way to ask for something?
Oh, am I lagging?
Am I okay?
Oh, I'm lagging a little bit.
Sorry.
Oh, uh...
What am I doing?
Opening?
Together!
It's no use!
I can't budget.
It must be stuck.
Oh, no!
Oh, my God.
No!
I got so far, please.
Wait, what just happened?
Oh!
What the?
The Kraken?
Why am I lagging?
Who?
The doctor?
What just happened?
I can't believe my eyes.
Lynn and the little lady suddenly vanish, leaving only
darkness and seawater.
The submarine continues to sink down, down into the deep,
deep sea.
But I still want to try and make my way up as far as
possible.
What just happened?
Still went to head up to find a single ray of light.
Light to illuminate the truth at the bottom of this deep,
deep darkness.
Thanks, Sissel.
So poetic.
What just... Who?
Huh?
The final struggle.
Okay.
What chapter are we on now?
17?
17.
Two more chapters!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
The upended submarine continues to sink slowly but surely.
A long, long journey to the bottom of the sea.
Lynn and the little lady found the darkness and the salt
water closing in on them.
But at the very last second, something saved them.
Now it looks down at them quietly.
Is it Ray?
The claw.
Oh my god, it looks like it has big old googly eyes.
My head is filled with one giant question.
What in the world is this thing?
Um.
What?
Eee!
Oh.
That only had enough.
What the?
What?
Oh my god, it's...
It's Dark Magician...
Wait, it's Sisa?
I see you managed to survive, detective.
Hey, you're...
Excuse my appearance.
I seem to have lost my body.
He looks so awesome.
Oh, no.
I'm into robots.
Oh, and you...
Me?
Minto?
You're the ghost who's been saving Lin all evening, aren't
you?
I mean yeah I guess you might say that I am the ghost that's
been doing all the work huh yeah you
knew about me all along of course what else would explain
all those unnatural things happening if you knew how come
you didn't do anything about it all this time and how come
you decided to save us all of a sudden I I thought you
wanted to get revenge on us.
Fourth wall break real.
I don't really know.
Please, you gotta tell me.
I need to know.
I'm back into a wisp.
Who in the world are you?
Cecil, look at you!
What happened?
I can't hold on to that image of myself any longer.
who you are?
That's right.
I'm a cool wisp.
It's you guys.
I came all this way tonight trying to chase down my lost
memory.
For quite a bit of tonight, I thought I was you, Sissel.
Sissel?
My name isn't Sissel.
Wait, but we knew that.
I bet you'll remember really soon.
Who you are and who I am too.
What?
the man in front of me is not me I'm even further away from
the truth or maybe not something is stirring in my mind a
memory about to emerge do I know this man now that I've shed
my image of myself I feel like I'm one step closer to the
truth info dump incoming let's go
but the water they got us good it's all over for this
submarine.
Its engine room is destroyed.
There's a hole in the hole.
Wait, there's a hole in the hole.
In the hole.
And it's sinking as we speak.
What are you doing here?
I thought you had to deal with those people.
They betrayed me.
I was a fool to trust them.
They already have what they wanted now.
But how do we still have the...
How does they still have the powers?
The Temsic fragment.
I didn't know they had it all figured out.
You mean they figured out the source of your powers?
A hole in the hull.
A hole in the hole in the hole in the hole in the hole in
the hole.
Yeah, that meteorite's radiation has two effects on living
creatures.
It gives power and time.
If you don't mind, we'd like to hear more.
Oh, the radiation's power effect.
These 10 years.
I've been watching that junkyard superintendent do his
research.
Hold me.
Yo, Mint, I heard you like drowning.
so I put a hole in the hole so you can sink while you sink
and I think I've kind of got some of it figured out the
meteorites radiation gives spirits special powers like
possessing and manipulating objects and in my case swapping
objects exactly apparently there are individual differences
in the powers we get and it seems these powers change as
time goes by they do yeah my powers have changed over these
past 10 years at first I could only manipulate small living
creatures now then how do you suppose we got these powers
it's simple it is how then in a nutshell we died while
exposed to the energy admitted by the meteorite.
It's radiation.
Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
That's what does it?
Dying while being exposed to the radiation?
On that day, 10 years ago.
Oh my gosh, we actually see his outline, his silhouette.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Butt up in the air, just like how he died again!
of that meteorite pierced my heart and I died.
So of course I received special powers.
It's a canon event.
Hey, wait a minute.
Is that how I got my powers, too?
You know that might be right.
No, I don't want to see it.
No!
Aren't the Temzik remnants still right there in that park at
the bottom of the crater?
You're right.
right.
So that must mean, I must have died in the presence of the
meteorite's radiation too.
The radiation's time effect.
Another effect the meteorite's radiation has on us is that
it gives us time.
Again, I think this time effect is centered around the theme
of death, but it's not all that clear.
So the fact that I can return to four minutes before a
person's death is another effect of that meteorite.
characteristics of that meteorite is that is its ability to
replay the moment of death replay the moment of death this
is all so strange and confusing i can't take it all in it
makes about as much sense to me as anything else yeah
strange and confusing that just about sums up the object
that pierced my body that day four minutes death hype yeah
Thanks to that meteorite fragment, my very existence is a
contradiction.
What do you mean?
Contradictory existence?
That day, when the fragment pierced my heart, I lost my
life.
However, because it remained inside me, that fragment
continued to constantly regenerate my body.
In other words, my body was continuously cycling between the
moments that separated my life and death.
my body is vital function stopped 10 years ago but my body's
time is perpetually stopped at the moment just before death
so that's why he doesn't um that's why he hasn't uh what's
the word oh my god
dissolved that's why he hasn't dissolved his body decomposed
decomposed yeah yeah I've been trying to think of decapote
that word all night and every time I just keep thinking of
dissolved time just stopped huh so I just simply existed not
really alive not really dead that pretty much sums up these
last 10 years for me ever since that incident in the park my
body hasn't aged a day my hair hasn't grown an inch that old
pigeon guy mentioned something.
He said he couldn't cut his...
this guy's body with the scapple.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Neither truly alive nor truly dead.
This game is becoming more and more like Metal Gear.
Anata no story now, Aata wa cool.
Thank you for the silver child.
So I guess as soon as an incision was made, his body would
be regenerated.
Wow.
This guy is just gray fox wanting to get revenge.
And also, not being able to be alive or dead.
After Tempsick.
Revenge.
Before I left this country, I wanted to do one thing.
I wanted to get revenge on the people who stole our lives.
Our lives.
As part of the deal, I made those guys promise to cooperate.
Cooperate?
You mean the kidnapping?
it all went fine I manipulated the justice minister and made
him issue the execution order but I thought he might call
off the execution at the last second so that's why you
wanted his daughter kidnapped but they kidnapped the wrong
girl who is our yeah unless unless also the wife no hmm
little did I know.
They had their own reasons for cooperating with me.
I mean, yeah, what would they get out of it if not having
their own reasons?
Their objective was to wipe out everybody who had to do with
Temsik.
Detective Jowd was one such person, so they were happy to
cooperate.
The professor and Detective Cabanella.
Inspector Cabanella and that junkyard super.
They were slated to be wiped out too.
And as it turns out...
Whoa!
I was one of their targets as well.
So they stole my Temsic fragment.
And here I am.
So cool.
I know, right?
But they had one more final target.
Lynn?
You, detective.
Hmm.
Me?
One final target.
Yeah, because you were there.
If you weren't there in the park that day, 10 years ago, I
never would have thought of doing something as stupid as
taking a hostage.
Okay.
Totally her fault, yep.
With her golden plunger, whatever the hell she's holding.
kid playing in the park yeah I know hmm 10 years later I
need to become a detective looking into Jowd's case it's
your fault I took you hostage I know right tonight I invited
you to a quiet spot on the edge of town there was a trap you
see so
I told you who I was so that's why then he her to shoot him
and then then they were going to assassinate her but wait
they didn't need to huh she was gonna get taken to jail
anyway you never saw my face that day ten years ago so of
course you didn't recognize me wait me no no he's like yep
what can I say he's so cool yeah see then I took possession
of you and to make you shoot me yeah yeah yeah get the gun
whoa he's so kakui your subconscious resisted me such
incredible power it was the first time I wasn't able to
control somebody completely the aim was all and the first
shot missed the mark.
Oh!
The junkyard was equipped with security cameras.
Wait a second.
The first shot that missed.
That's what killed me!
That's what killed original Cicel!
Wait, but...
Where...
Oh.
What did it hit?
Where did it go?
But it was down!
The junkyard was equipped with security cameras.
I knew you'd be wanted for murder.
That was my plan anyway.
Uh-oh.
What if you're a raccoon?
And then it's, um...
But they had other ideas.
They simply wanted to be wiped out.
Ah, okay, okay.
But then, something threw a big monkey wrench into their
scheme.
Because if we're close to the body, if we died close to the
body, then of course we would get the powers.
I show- Are we a rat?
Oh my gosh, are we a rat?
We've been a rat this whole time?
Are we a rat?
No way.
That's why we've been following the rats.
Oh my gosh, we're a rat.
Remember how I said it's like we're not human.
I showed up.
You shot a rat.
I was supposed to meet up with them after that.
But then something went wrong.
What happened?
My body disappeared.
Aha.
in white was responsible for that one.
Stop reading, chat.
I'm not!
I'm not.
When I'm cooking, I'm really, I'm really just thinking.
But also, don't spoil stuff.
Do not read, chat?
Okay, I won't read chat.
Stop reading, chat.
If you guys are posting spoilers, stop it.
My precious bargaining chip was in that body.
I had to get it back no matter what.
Spectre caused me no end of trouble.
But why were those people targeting me?
I never even heard of the Tempsic meteorite.
Because you were looking into the Jowd case.
They thought you would find out about Tempsic sooner or
later.
Okay.
I guess that's true.
Uh-oh.
How do we get out of here?
This is so titanic.
It's scary.
That's pretty much the whole story.
The only thing left to do now is wait for water pressure to
crush the submarine.
Oh, no!
There's no cores that link from here to the water surface.
Welcome back, after midnight.
Thank you.
I have an idea.
We hook up the phone line and...
There are no communication cables down this deep.
They meant for this submarine to be my coffin.
A coffin for the dead.
There's no escape
I think I kind of understand now What you've been feeling
these 10 years You what?
This feeling Cut off from the world all alone in a submarine
Sinking slowly towards the bottom of an endless sea This
must be how you felt all along
Oh, Camilla's awake
Lynn Is it true?
We're stuck here?
What?
Oh, oh, oh, at least she's comfy, right?
If my dad, if my dad was here, I bet he'd save us.
No, this can't be the end.
Oh, Camilla, I'm so sorry.
funny what is it sisal there's something i don't understand
why would they go to all the trouble of detaching the
control room what why didn't they just steal the tempsic
fragment and escape if that's what they wanted why did they
have to jettison your body off into the sea that's a good
question well because he could still get around right he
could still uh but I guess it doesn't matter why now we'll
never find it again we have no idea where it was launched to
wait a minute yes we do oh my gosh he has the pocket watch
this will tell us where Detective Jowd is that present from
the inspector in white that's right Detective Jowd told me
to hold on to it for him And the bullet is still in this
person's body in the command room, right?
Oh, nice!
Then we should be able to tell exactly where it is with
this.
But even if we find out where it is, how do we get there?
We should be able to figure out something between the three
of us.
With our powers.
Right, Miss Lynn!
Right.
Wait, are we going to get the manipulating powers?
Wait a minute, what about a torpedo?
A torpedo?
In any case, it's way too early to give up.
Looks like Detective Jowd is our last hope.
Let's get started.
Oh my gosh.
Let's...
We got the bottle.
We got...
The control panel.
Let's operate this.
Beep-bop-bop-bip.
Oh!
Some grapes?
No.
Nice.
We won't starve.
Telephone dial.
Torpedo room.
The torpedo room, huh?
There might be another torpedo left there.
I'll go check it out.
Yeah, there was one.
Going to use a missile to ram the control room.
Well, I don't know about ram.
We don't want to blow Detective Jowd up.
But something like that.
We'll climb up to the torpedo room too.
Up is definitely safer.
I'll see you there, then.
I like how we still have the glasses on.
Looks like the torpedoes can be launched manually with these
switches.
There are two tubes, so there should be one left.
I guess the first thing we have to do is load it into the
tube.
When it comes to missiles, you can count on me.
Okay.
I'll enter the...
coordinates of the of the command room into the torpedo and
I just turned on the backup power we ought to be able to use
the switches now okay let's try it good luck so what do I do
lower the switch or yeah lower the switch won't budge maybe
it's broken I don't think the entire device is broken would
probably work Find if I can move this switch.
We'll just have to find a way to move it somehow.
But I can't do it with my powers alone.
Do you like my sunglasses?
Thanks for the super chat.
It's because he's not a ghost.
He's a shade.
Ah, ha, ha, ha.
So true.
What kind of ghost do you think I am?
Let's turn this valve.
See what this does.
Nothing.
Do I go to the end?
engine room?
A phantom?
Good guess.
Hmm.
The phone line to the engine room isn't working right now.
Well, that water probably damaged the line.
I guess we don't need to go back there anyway.
Okay.
Uh, wait.
Can I get you to move there, Missile?
What will happen to these two ladies?
I think that's up to us and our powers.
What?
This is no time to be standing around unsure of ourselves.
Will you lend me your strength missile?
Me?
Of course I will.
Count on it!
Okay, there we go.
I'm not quite sure what I...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Waste basket?
Basketball.
There's still stuff here.
Telephone.
Emergency light.
Can't reach over there.
Maybe if we go here.
Here.
Oh.
Still no, but let's try lowering anyway.
Okay, it didn't do anything.
Where is the torpedo that we're supposed to be...
That we're supposed to be...
putting in there right or something cleared the same same
challenge I unlocked the song same save Wow I had no idea
your deaths a silky ghost made of a house hmm was I a made
of a house though I wonder hmm it
allows me to go down here But I'm not quite sure what I'm
supposed to be doing here.
Telephone.
Oh, wait a second.
Oh, I'm silly.
I'm so silly.
Okay, I get what I'm supposed to be doing here now.
Okay, we gotta...
We're switching the handles.
I get it.
I get it now.
I'm silly.
Oh, wait.
How do I get over into the handle though?
There we go.
Switch!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
And then...
Go back down.
And then we can swap...
Lower.
Oh wait, I mean, sorry.
The other one.
Whoopsie.
This one.
Lower!
Okay.
There we go.
A torpedo looks serviceable.
Switching the switches.
I'll set on this end too.
Something's odd.
What is?
The command room.
It looks like it's slowly sinking.
Yeah, like it's completely run out of power.
I wonder what happened.
Uh-oh.
I don't know, but I guess I'll find out.
Okay, hop into the missile.
I'll launch it for you.
Thanks.
Here we go.
I'm scared.
Is Detective Jowd gonna be alive?
I've already set the torpedoes course.
It'll head toward the command room where Detective Jowd is.
12 seconds after launching, it'll pass by the command room
for an instant.
That instant will be your window of opportunity to jump over
to the command room.
Got it.
And then we'll find a way to come back and save you.
That'll probably be my last task tonight.
Just hold on until we get back.
Where is Evil Sissel?
He didn't... he didn't... he didn't show up?
Okay, come on, Missal.
Missile, you have to come with us.
Missile?
I...
I'm sorry.
I can't go.
What?
I just can't.
How could I leave?
I can't leave Miss Lynn and Miss Camilla behind.
I can't do it.
Missile.
I swapped the switches so the missile can be launched.
You'll have to do the rest, Sisile.
I can't do it either.
Missal to come with me after that.
I understand exactly how he feels.
Yeah, bring Evil Sisal!
Come with us, Evil Sisal!
Okay.
Oh, I guess we're gonna go.
I want you to go, Missal.
What?
But Miss Lynn!
You staying here won't change our fate.
But if you go with Sisal, you might be able to make
something happen.
And that's our only hope.
But what if that something doesn't happen?
I'll never be able to see you again Never ever again Even I
can understand that I couldn't stand that Don't worry,
Missal Miss Camilla I just know you and Sissy Can make
something happen, I believe in you I'll be right here
waiting for you We'll see each other then Don't worry
Miss Camilla Come below!
Here he goes.
That's a good boy, Missou.
Why'd you have to make such a lovable dog?
Are you ready?
Remember, it's 12 seconds after I throw this switch.
We're ready.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I hope.
It's gonna count down for me, right?
Cicel?
yes we never found out who you really were but that doesn't
matter now all I know is I'm truly glad I met you tonight
thank you for everything and I'm glad I met you detective
but we're going to see each other again right sissy right
missile that's right we promise little lady of course we
will I'll never forget you no matter what happens this is
such a death flag oh my god here goes then don't promise
anything good luck friend no
these 12 seconds are lasting in eternity i strive to think
of a way to save lynn and the little lady the whole time but
how can a ray of light a ray of hope reach this far down
into the deep sea.
Before I can think of an answer, the 12 seconds are up.
Whoa!
Woo!
Uh-oh.
There they go.
Detective Jowd!
I bet that big masked man did this.
I'm going to bite him.
Yeah, you bite him.
You better not.
You might break your teeth.
The command room has lost power and is sinking.
So I wonder what this masked man is going to do.
himself he's going to sacrifice himself no you can't let's
talk to detective jowd
sorry for the wait detective jowd who are you are you sizzle
please excuse my appearance I can't believe you made it here
how is Camilla and what about Lynn well it's kind of a long
story
Then that's how they explain it really quickly in Animal
Crossing talk.
I told Detective Jad about everything that happened on the
submarine, Yo Mama.
So the submarine is badly damaged?
Oh, why would he do that to his own submarine?
I wish I knew.
I know the answer to that one.
Whoa!
It's because he's afraid of my powers.
Hey, excuse me?
You!
You followed us?
I didn't even notice.
It's been 10 long years, Detective Jowd.
Are you...
Yo-Miel?
So you remember me, do you?
How could I possibly forget?
So that's your real name, huh?
that's interesting that's right but those people on on the
Yonoa were calling you sisal that's just an alias I was
using for my deal with them I didn't see any need to tell
them my real name could you do me a favor would you let me
ask you some questions I've been trying to find out my true
identity all night Yomiel is named after a fallen angel and
Yomi, the Shinto land of the dead.
In Shu Takumi tradition, most character names in the game
are puns and references, in this case related to death.
Ah, ah, ah, interesting, interesting.
It's Yomiyeru, so yep, you're reading it right.
Okay, nice.
Thank you.
Sure, go ahead.
I'm sure there's plenty we can still tell you, right,
Detective Jowd?
Right.
About Yomiya.
10 years ago.
You were a top systems engineer, weren't you?
Systems engineer?
What's that?
By the way, I'm a top Pomeranian, you know?
Yes, you are, Missal.
Well, it's kind of hard to explain to a dog, but it's a
person who's good at using computers.
I don't mean to brag, but I was one of the best in the
industry.
Oh my God, he's a hacker.
That's how I got roped into joining that project.
project what project it was a project aimed at reorganizing
the nation's top secret information the goal was to build a
new system using multi-dimensional programming theory I was
asked to join the project by an agent of the government it
doesn't sound like something a top Pomeranian would know
anything about to me it just sounded like another
challenging job Hacker man.
However, this project was also the target of a secret plot.
I bet you can imagine the kind of crime the nation's top
secrets might attract.
I never thought for the life of me I'd ever have to deal
with spies.
It was never made public, but every organization in the
country moved on this one.
And then one day, the name of a certain programmer emerged
as a suspect.
I was the guy who built the core of the system The police
arrested you and then that incident happened He escaped from
the interrogation room and took little Lynn as a hostage
Hold on one second I gotta check something real quick guys
sorry Okay Never mind I never got an answer By the way,
Detective Jowd.
When was it that I was proven innocent?
About six months after your death.
I'm so sorry, Yomiya.
He was framed.
Real motive for revenge.
Ten years ago.
My soul was split from my body and I lost everything.
I was sealed in eternal darkness.
Wow!
Look at him go!
I existed in this world, no question about that.
But nobody noticed my presence.
Look at him go!
What good were my powers?
They didn't help anybody.
Not even the passage of time to heal my pain.
In fact, it only made it worse.
I wanted to disappear.
I wasn't even allowed to do that.
The way Lynn described it is exactly right.
Sinking slowly toward the bottom of an endless sea.
An overwhelming feeling of loneliness and despair.
And I wanted all of you to suffer what I was suffering.
Aww.
And so that's why you murdered Alma.
That's right.
I wanted you to know what it was like to lose everything
everything you cared about.
I wanted you to feel the same pain I felt.
But that's not entirely right, right?
It was the twisted wish of a mind poisoned by infinite
loneliness.
Yeah.
And then, as I was plotting my revenge, I had an idea.
I came up with a plan to use these powers of mind to make a
deal.
The deal.
What's the deal?
What's the deal with Ghost Trick?
There's something I just don't understand about that deal.
I'm sure your powers would be very valuable to them.
But what would you get out of the deal?
A new life.
Life.
I asked them for two conditions.
Number one was that they helped me with my revenge plot.
And the second was a rebirth for me.
Rebirth.
A new beginning, eh?
I didn't care if it was a fake life, an artificial life.
I just wanted a physical receptacle for my soul, a name, an
identity, an everyday life.
I wanted to grow old in a society that would accept me.
And finally, I wanted to die, surrounded by a loving family.
That's the kind of life I asked them for.
A completely man-made life.
Step one.
Revenge.
Step two.
Become baby.
That's right.
I knew I couldn't hope for anything more than that.
To make it all come true, I knew it would take a lot of
money and a lot of power.
That's why I decided to ask a national government to help
me.
And the response in the end was betrayal.
Betrayal.
They were making their moves much more carefully than I
suspected.
They sent spies to this country and researched my powers on
their own.
And they even figured out what Temsik was all about.
And you had no idea they were doing all this?
None at all.
I was a fool.
So then, why did they go to all the trouble of making a deal
with you?
Why didn't they just steal a hunk of the Temsik meteorite
from the park?
They couldn't.
Huh?
Oh, oh?
After the manipulator incidents, research was conducted in
this country too.
A report was submitted to the government about the source of
the manipulator's power.
Okay.
By Inspector Cabanela and the old pigeon guy, eh?
at first the government didn't believe the report but then
they decided to put put the park under surveillance just in
case wait it's not the hippie guy is it surveillance huh it
looks like an ordinary peaceful park but there are armed
agents there at all times like him don't tell me that odd
leaflet guy is one of them no not him he's just a plain old
odd person okay he's just a weirdo just a weirdo everybody
nothing to see here that park is like a silent battlefield
on an international scale so that's why they couldn't steal
the Temsic meteorite and lately under the pretense of
building a housing site they've been working on a plan to
destroy that park in order to secure the Oh, so that's it.
So the upshot of your grand deal was this, eh?
Yeah.
It's the ending I deserve.
But at least there's one thing you must be happy about.
What's that?
You've managed to seal me away at the bottom of the sea
forever.
Well, shall we get started?
It started with what?
Bringing Detective Jowd back to life, of course.
What?
What good will that do now?
But we promised.
We promised Miss Lynn and Miss Camilla we'd save them.
Then we can't do that without you, Detective Jowd.
I've been guided by fate tonight to this place.
I won't give up now.
Alright, fine.
Let's see where it leads us.
Oh, gosh, there's so much reading, you guys.
I'm getting so tired.
I'm sorry.
Here we go, then.
Back to four minutes before your death.
Trying to get hungry, too.
You're almost at the end.
We have one more chapter after this.
But this shouldn't be so much reading, probably, because
we're figuring out the puzzle.
GAMBARE!
Thank you!
So, where are we headed?
We are not headed anywhere, detective.
For the mystery of Cicil identity, you have been given all
the clues needed.
Take a hot minute before diving into the final chapter.
For chat, hush, no spoilers.
No, it's okay.
I think I will just go into the final chapter.
It's no worries.
I want to see what they...
I think I've cooked enough.
You know?
I think I want to see what the answer is.
Oh.
What?
There was only enough fuel on board to launch us away,
detective.
We will run out soon and that will be our destination,
Wait, does this guy actually just sacrifice himself?
What are you talking about?
That would mean...
That you're trapped here too!
By the way, I am not human, detective.
I am a remote-controlled robot, detective!
No!
What?
Your country's use of technology is just playing off.
We get that a lot, detective.
Um, I don't know.
Uh, give me robot girls and I'm in, actually.
Why would you go to all the trouble to do this?
That's nothing but a shell there.
It's hardly a threat anymore.
Commander Sith likes to provide any...
Any possibility, no matter how small, detective.
Possibility.
Yeah, we got robot girls.
We have blue women.
I think this other country is great.
And where's my robot girls at?
What are you talking about?
There's no need for you to know, detective.
Smack.
Oh!
Now it's time to say goodbye, detective.
Murph, thanks for a month.
Thank you.
In the end, your fate remains the same, it seems.
Grr.
Camilla.
Forgive me.
Maybe Shaggy's a robot.
Good.
I can't wait to dismantle that guy.
To teeny tiny pieces.
By every little bit and bot.
It's not over yet.
Not yet, Jowd.
Remember what that big mask man said?
Any possibility, no matter how small.
Possibility.
In other words, there must be a chance here somewhere.
The possibility of turning this situation around.
Do we get other powers?
Do we get the powers of...
Do we get the powers of manipulation?
Okay, let's see what we got here.
Huh?
What is it, Detective?
Look at Yomiya's shell.
There's no aura emanating from his body.
Of course there isn't.
The Temsik fragment is gone.
Could this change in his shell give us some kind of lead?
I figured it out.
I know what this possibility no matter...
That was fast.
This possibility no matter small, no matter how small, is
that they are afraid of.
What?
What is it?
That was so fast.
My time was perpetually stopped.
Thanks to the power of Temsik.
His body cycled between the moments that separated his life
and death.
But not anymore.
Can we?
Wait.
The Temsik fragment has been taken away.
So what does that mean?
No.
I get it.
Your body won't come back to life anymore the moment the
Temsic fragment was removed my shell became a regular corpse
that means we can we can go back four minutes before your
death but wait a minute exactly when is that death ten years
ago that's simple we'll find out when we get there Let's
move!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god!
How do we stop a whole ass meteor?
I fell back through the cracks of time for what seemed like
forever.
And then I saw it.
The final death.
At the end of this long night!
Who exactly am I?
I've already seen all the clues.
All I have to do now is remember!
The final journey to the truth starts now.
Oh, oh!
Okay, final chapter, everybody.
Four minutes before death variation.
Oh, cool!
Oh, awesome!
Okay, here we go, everybody.
Last chapter.
Final chapter.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
When was Yomiel's death?
It was 10 years ago when the Tempsic meteorite fell.
We traveled back through time, and now we're here at the
scene of that death.
The start of it all is about to replay itself.
Oh my gosh.
Here comes the meteor.
Four minutes before death.
Oh wow, what a pretty park.
so she's jamming it's whoa oh my gosh she was making she was
making yaki yimo she was making sweet potato I thought it
was a plunger give it up do you really think you can outrun
me she was cooking let her eek now just calm down and drop
that weapon stay back if you come any closer thank you You
can already get who you are.
I have no idea anymore.
I'll shoot her.
Oh, baby.
Huh?
Oh, a kitten.
Show you.
Random cat.
You might get hurt.
Whoa!
It's beautiful.
Oh, my gosh.
And then the whole human race was extinct.
Oh, okay.
Is that going to have to do something with it somehow?
Stellar, stellar.
The cat's okay, right?
Are you okay?
Where'd the cat go?
You're all right now.
Are you hurt?
You saved me, Mr. Oh wait, hold on.
You saved me, mister.
I was just doing my job.
The gods, they're the ones who saved you.
What's your job, mister?
Me?
I'm a police detective.
so that's the Temsic radio right it's beautiful looking at
it oh it's beautiful looking at it from this angle it
changed all of our fates completely we can't stop Temsic
from falling from the sky but we might be able to protect
you from the fragment and save your life I'm so glad you
played one of my favorite games.
The gameplay and story is 10 out of 10.
How people play more games like this in the future.
Also, 10 out of 10 voice acting.
Thank you.
Thank you so much to the Super Chat.
I don't know.
What's the matter, Detective Jowler?
To be perfectly honest, I'm scared.
If that meteorite fragment doesn't get him, I'm pretty sure
I would have shot him.
We might not be able to change your fate of dying.
I can accept that.
What I did is inexcusable.
No matter how the future might change, that fact will never
go away.
It's my fate to die here.
Then I accept that.
Oh, if my fate is to die here, then I accept that.
This will be our last battle against fate.
Beyond that will be a new future.
Okay, let's get started!
Meso is still here.
I'm so happy.
Okay, I feel like we're gonna have to probably use Missile's
powers to swap something, right?
Um...
All right, let's see what we got here.
We can't... I can't reach.
Missile just hanging out in the basket.
We got a nozzle.
Maybe we have to shoot the...
Sweet potato!
Oh, I want to roast the sweet potatoes so badly right now!
Headphones.
Okay.
We don't have much going on here.
It's ready!
Let's make it!
Oh!
Okay.
Cat.
Examine the sweet potato.
What in the world is this thing?
It's making me hungry.
What do you even forgot what a sweet potato is?
It's a roasted root vegetable.
That's good.
Oh my gosh.
If you've never had roasted sweet potato, it's one of the
best things ever.
So good.
There's nothing like them on a cold...
Like them on a cold winter's day.
They're sweet and they smell delicious.
These guys sure are making me want to try one.
I still can't reach.
Hmm.
I have to switch this and this.
I have to switch this and this, I think.
Right?
The god rock.
Yeah.
Can I go grab some food real quick?
Sorry.
It's already done, so I'm just gonna grab it.
I'll be two seconds to grab it.
Sorry, I started to get shaky all of a sudden.
Oh, I'm a hungry ghost.
I'm a hungry ghost.
Sorry, sorry for the break.
So sorry.
I wanna continue the story.
I wanna see what happens.
But I need break.
I mean it fueled for my for my mushy brain.
Sorry I won't be able to voice act this part anything.
Poor Miss Lin.
I'm sorry.
If you're so sorry then put her down.
I won't be able to voice act this.
Just reads it anyway.
Alright now Missil.
I was really out of my mind.
head that day.
We can talk about all this later.
A Temsec meteorite is gonna fall very soon.
Before that happens, I have to think of a way to do
something about that fragment.
And I'll do everything I can to help too.
Okay, um... We really don't have very many places we can go.
Let's have some more time pass.
Look at the cat!
Time is passing.
No, so cute!
Nothing else happens!
It's about time for that meteorite to come down!
Uh oh.
We have to change the fragment's path somehow!
Looks like both paths and fates can be difficult things to
change.
There has to be a way.
If we work together, you and me, I thought we'd be able to
do something.
Thought?
That's funny.
I wonder why he's using past tense.
Uh...
That's so cute!
Kind of reminds me...
It reminds me of Paus.
Okay, let's redo it.
So this is the start of it all, huh?
We can change Rute Yomiya's fate.
What will happen to everything else, I wonder?
It won't do us any good to think about that now.
We just have to take that first step forward.
Just as we always do.
Rewind!
Oh.
Okay.
I can't reach until he grabs her.
Why can't we switch around?
Is the basket and the...
The...
Are the basket and the sweet potato when she grabs them?
Are they the same shape?
Let's see.
Do they count as the same shape?
It was just that this cat just walks up.
So funny.
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Ah!
Oh, man, I already missed my opportunity, maybe.
We can examine the sweep.
Oh, we can turn up the headphones.
Oh, I didn't realize that.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
What are you doing?
You're going to hurt poor Miss Lynn's ears!
I'm sorry, I wasn't thinking.
You really startled her.
You could have even made her drop her sweet potato.
how much this girl loves her food too anyway at least her
fate has been changed I'll be ever so slightly okay I'm
going ghost okay nice nice nice we're gonna have you go all
the way not there oh wait we have to go from here to there
there we go okay we can rock the basket we can spray the
nozzle okay I was thinking that spray okay
Can I switch the nozzles?
Oh, I can't reach.
Because I'm gonna say if I could switch the nozzles, maybe
one will, they'll be, he could like, spray sisal, you know?
Oh, Raid!
Thank you!
Yuki!
Wait, oh gosh, I didn't see the other name.
I'm so sorry.
YouTube is really stupid right now.
And all raids come in a white text on white background, so I
can't read them.
Thank you!
Thank you so much to the raid!
Oh, Yuki and Yuna.
Thank you.
Right now, I'm in the final chapter of this game.
So, kind of major spoilers, but...
Welcome.
Let's see.
Marry, thanks for the gifted.
Let's rock this, I guess.
Let's see what happens here.
Rock the boat.
Oh, oh, and we showed it up.
Ghost, ghost, oh, whoops, wait, I pressed the wrong button.
What did I just press?
Oh, okay, that scared me.
Heart Underblade, thank you for the five gifted.
Shopkeeper, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you guys.
Okay, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Here we go.
And shoot!
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I think I missed my opportunity.
That was kind of disappointing.
Maybe the timing was a little off.
I better try it again.
How do I...
Get it back over here though.
Ah!
Oh, I had it, but I didn't have it.
Okay, let's just restart.
After the fight change, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
We have one chance.
Rock the boat.
And then go to here.
And then buck.
Oh my god, I can't see it!
Okay.
Go ghost.
Oh, okay.
Look at that sweet potato.
That big, scary sweet...
That big, scary sweet potato.
That's not a sweet potato missile.
That's minto.
You guys, I'm a sweet potato.
I can't believe I'm in the game.
Alright, of course.
But look at them.
The potato and mino.
Right now, they both have the same shape.
So you're saying you could swap them, huh?
Good idea, Missile.
Here I go.
And I'm gonna need your help.
My help.
Uh-oh, my help.
Oh, spray higher.
Be.
Wait a second.
Uh, no, no, wait.
Uh, wait, wait, wait.
Uh, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, oh, wait, wait.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
Okay, that's all I can do.
I can't...
Um...
I had it.
What do you mean I had it?
Uh...
Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Can I reach it now?
No.
Can I reach it from here?
Huh?
Wait.
I need you to move, Sis-o!
You're in my way!
You're in my way, Sis-o!
It's right there, come on.
Hey, hey, hey.
Don't be mean about it, okay?
Just because I get something not as quickly as you do
doesn't mean you have to be mean about it.
Oh my god.
I need you to raise it again.
Raise the roof!
There we go.
Maybe.
I guess.
That was quite a sight to see.
It looks like this park just got a new feature.
But neither one of them even glanced this way.
I guess that's not surprising, seeing as even a meteorite
didn't distract them.
Hey, it was a desperate situation.
Kill or be killed.
right after this by the meteorite.
Well, now that the park has a new feature, we can use it to
our own advantage in any...
Or can we use it to our own advantage in any way?
Okay.
Cleared the first...
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
What can you do?
Spray any higher?
You're literally stuck.
Okay, Cicil is stuck.
Stuckle.
Yeah, let's try the water just a tiny bit.
There's no use.
I can't get any water to come out.
Well, we can see why not.
Yeah, the overwhelming presence of Minto.
If only we could use it to our advantage somehow.
How can we use it to our...
Um...
Is there anything that I can...
Anything that I can...
Hmm.
What can I do with it?
With it?
Oh wait!
Post Lantern.
Um...
There's one more core there is.
Over here?
No.
I don't know.
I'm trying to figure it out.
I'm just going everywhere.
I'm just...
Use it to our advantage.
Use it to our advantage that no water is coming out.
I'm only glancing at chat sometimes.
Even if people are giving answers, I'm most likely not
seeing it.
So you guys can be like, stop backseating.
But it's okay.
I'm not watching.
I'm not looking at it either.
I'm not really seeing anyone telling me what to do either.
Oh,
here we go.
I guess we'll just play it out and see what happens.
I doubt we can move those two from that spot.
Which means we have to do something with the Temsic fragment
instead.
That should be easy with our power.
with the fragment, huh?
I think you're right, Missal.
This is going, this is going to be the grand finale.
Huh?
Do something with the fragment?
Oh my gosh, I forgot it was from all the way back here.
Rock!
Mew!
Oh my gosh, I can't see it.
Now, that's there.
And then spray higher.
Oh, wait.
Can I reach it?
Yeah.
Like that.
And then we go back about here.
Can I go down just a little bit?
Oh, right there.
so close wait can i reach it from here oh so close uh um
okay just a little bit higher
spray spray please wait oh wait oh no no wait oh i can't i
forgot that i need to do it from down here oh my gosh it's
the timing of it um
Maybe here?
Way overthinking.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
There we go.
Now I have to do it.
Now, now.
There we go.
Oh my goodness.
Spray, please.
There we go.
I'm good.
Swap.
Okay.
This is
what I wanted to do from the beginning.
The lamppost is bending.
But it hasn't broken yet.
It really is a wonder.
It hasn't snapped.
It just might hold out for a little while longer.
If I recall, the Temsik fragment smashed through the glass
lantern on its way down.
But if Mino sits firmly in its way, then fate should- Oh,
goodbye, Lin.
Goodbye, Lin.
Is there anything else I could do here?
I think, um...
I think this is it.
Oh!
There!
How's that?
Look, the fragment's course!
It changed a little!
Now, Yomiya's fate should really change.
Wait a minute.
Take another look at the fragment's trajectory.
Uh-oh.
Now that it's changed, what's in its path?
In its path?
No!
Only
got hit in the leg, though.
fragment shot through his leg!
It's okay!
It's only his leg!
But the cruel twist of fate weren't over yet.
Oh, what do you mean by that?
Um, come on, put it down.
Jowd, put the gun down now!
If you don't, you're going to shoot him!
I don't know if it's his detective training or what.
But even though he's shaking from the pain, the gun doesn't
waver.
Put the gun down!
No!
Oh my god.
I knew it.
This is my true fate.
In the end, I stole his life away with my own hands.
Or you missed.
Oh!
Let's go!
I won't let that happen!
Missile!
But the bullet stopped.
It stopped in mid-air!
I'm here inside the bullet!
Now let's swap it with something.
What?
With what?
Detective Jowd.
The meteorite fragment is what made you pull the trigger.
We won't let you become a meteor.
We won't let you become a...
We have to prove that murder isn't the detective's true
fate.
To do that, we have to stop this bullet.
There must be something with the same shape as the bullet
around here.
Eat that!
Oh!
Sorry, that was really loud.
Oh my god!
We stopped the bullet.
Oh, he still couldn't save him.
That's not true.
My fate of getting pierced through the back might not have
changed.
But I'm still alive.
What?
I'm not dead.
I'm just unconscious.
I mean, for now?
Okay, so your fate of death has changed.
But still, this fate is just too painful to watch in every
sense.
I don't think so.
As long as I'm alive, that's good enough for me.
But we were overlooking one thing.
The wheel of fate was still slowly turning.
No!
Wake up!
You gotta get out of there!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Damn it, my leg won't work!
It's all over!
We're out of time!
Miss Lynn!
It's not over yet!
But there isn't anything else to swap with!
Why don't we just let it play out and then try to find
another way next time?
Even if she dies, all you have to do is possess her corpse.
And then you can redo her last four minutes as many times as
it takes!
Wait, that's what I...
No, I won't do that!
Why not?
Sure, the fact of her death would be erased, but her memory
of it would remain like a scar on her psyche.
I won't let that happen, not if I can help it.
What can we do now?
Even if we work together!
I think there might be something that can be done.
What is it?
What can Sissel and I do?
Don't forget I'm here too.
We finally, finally!
Oh wow.
You know, you could have helped out, you know, at any point
in the future, like in the past.
With three kinds of powers among us among us we ought to be
able to fight this battle this battle against the fate of
death yo mia sisal your power is manipulating objects use
your power to manipulate this huh I don't get it just trust
me just go all right I'll try to move there now gather your
strength and make it spray as if your life depended on it.
I'm dead though.
He's just like me for real, for real.
In that case, make it spray as if you're death depended on
it.
Give it your all.
And remember, you only have a split second.
Okay, now do it!
Got it!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
Now it's your turn, Missile!
What?
Uh, me?
But what can I do?
I think you know an answer to that.
Okay, got it.
You could swap them.
That hunk of concrete will go back to its original position.
Wait, but it's still going to be flying through the air.
Wait, I don't think you thought this through.
But even if I swap them, it's still going to be right above
Miss Lynn.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Okay, I'll do it.
I'll swap them.
Okay.
It's no use, we can't stop that horrible Meno!
What can we do now?
I don't see how gaining a second or two helped.
Oh, it helped, alright.
Those few seconds were exactly what I wanted.
Last up, it's my turn.
Your turn.
Him.
You know what my power is, right?
I can manipulate living creatures.
Wait a minute, you mean...
That's right.
I'm going to save that little girl.
Save her by manipulating my own unconscious body.
Oh!
He got...
Penny redeemed himself.
Oh my god.
You're awake.
Mr. Is your knee okay?
Oh, it'll be fine.
I'm lucky it wasn't a fatal hit, but the main thing is that
you're not hurt.
You saved me, mister.
I was just doing my job.
The gods, they're the ones who saved you.
What's your job, mister?
I'm a police detective.
Do you think you could go call the police for me?
I think you could do it quicker than I could.
What?
What's that?
This is a detective's badge.
We give them to children who've been very brave.
A detective's badge?
Aww.
No, so cute.
Thanks.
You know what to do, little detective.
Are you alive?
Yeah, sadly.
He's still alive.
I thought it was a lollipop too.
Hang on, help is coming.
What made you do such a reckless thing?
To be perfectly honest, I don't really know.
They all don't remember.
We basically went back in time entirely.
When I came to, my body was already moving by itself.
It was as if somebody else was controlling me.
I see.
But you know, I'm glad it happened.
I found this kitten.
It was over there.
No, no, no, no.
Come to think of it.
I just saw it a few minutes ago.
It's probably astray.
It's alive, right?
It's kind of limp.
Is it okay?
I don't know.
I think it's unconscious.
Okay, it's unconscious.
It's unconscious.
It's funny.
It doesn't look like it's injured or anything.
I thought the...
Poor little kitty.
Mm-hmm.
How about if I take it to my house and look after it?
Would you like to come home with me, a little kitten?
Well, it looks like his fate just changed in a big way.
Whose fate?
That kittens, of course.
You're absurd.
Why did you have to?
In the middle.
Hey!
Cicels!
Cicel?
The name Cicel echoes in my head.
That's my real name.
So we weren't a rat!
We were a cat!
These long, lonely ten years.
You were my one and only friend.
No, me?
How about it?
Do you remember now?
Whoa!
Oh, so cute.
Old friend.
Oh.
Oh my God, we're awesome.
I think, I think I finally remember.
10 years ago, I was a little kitten that wandered into this
park.
I was weak and all alone in the world.
Hold it.
God, why am I crying?
Somebody, please look at me.
No.
The kitten.
That's why I didn't know anything.
No.
So cute.
Somebody please reach a hand out to me.
Oh, and he can manipulate.
I had just only died at the time.
I had lost everything.
My life, my memory, my body wouldn't move anymore, but I
still managed to reach a hand out of hand to him.
The next thing I knew, my soul, I transferred to the black
kitten.
with no recollection of who I was.
I lived as a cat with you for a while.
After a while, the man regained his memory.
I went back to being just a cat.
And then the man got his body back.
Gosh, I wish I were a cat.
I took my body back from the morgue.
There was somebody I just had to go see.
Just one more time.
I took control of my body and hurried to her house
But I was just a little too late
His wife
I just missed her as she left this world She left me a note
that said I'm coming to you, Yom Yom Yow
The man named me Sissel It was the name of something
important had lost along with his life his fiance he told me
about it once but I didn't understand what it was
those 10 years were very happy for me but they weren't happy
for the man there was nothing I could do for him
for 10 years I wandered through the darkness with no
particular place to go
As time passed, my powers gradually changed.
At first, I could only manipulate small creatures and
objects.
But then after a while, I could manipulate people.
That's when the darkness inside me deepened and I started to
get a little twisted.
I wanted light.
Distorted artificial light.
revenge on Lin.
I would see that light.
Or at least that's what I tried to believe.
I left my old self buried in that junkyard and walked away.
Wait, did we see this?
Before?
I don't remember.
The black cat.
I was possessing Cicel then.
It wouldn't look very much like a murder if the corpse got
up and walked away after all.
Yeah, we did way back, right?
Yeah.
So you borrowed the body of your old friend.
Aww.
Cicel was inside that bag I was carrying tonight.
Why would you bring your cat?
I had no intention of leaving my friend behind in this
country when I left.
But then, when I went to possess his body.
I realized something horrible.
What was that?
Cicel there inside the back, man.
Oh man, why are you having to kill him again?
Not the cat.
I wasn't able to control her completely.
No.
The first bullet didn't hit anything.
Or so, I thought.
But it did hit something.
It hits it so much.
That's so sad.
That's when I lost my life.
Right there in the presence of Temsic radiation.
And that's when I got my powers of the dead, my ghost
tricks.
I think I understand it now.
Why, I was the only one who couldn't get his memory back.
It was because I thought that corpse was me.
Yeah, because he took off with the body.
It was the only corpse I could see at the time, after all.
But as it turns out, it wasn't the only dead body.
My true death was hiding just behind that corpse.
Now I think about it, do you remember what you said?
That you knew all along about me saving Lin tonight?
If you knew, why didn't you try to stop me?
It's simple.
Because I couldn't, even if I wanted to.
Why not?
Remember the thing about individual differences and the
powers we get?
I can control all kinds of things, from the living to the
dead.
But even so, there are some things that you can do that I
can't.
You mean, I can't even rewind time, let alone change the
fate of a death.
If I could do those things, I would have saved your life.
Not only that, but I never would have just let my fianc
stay dead like that.
But you're here 10 years in the past now!
That's thanks to your powers.
I just tagged along with you.
In any case.
Now the starting point of this entire tragedy has changed
dramatically, altering fate.
The fate of your death.
The kitten sisal's fate.
And I can just bet you the fate of the woman you love.
has changed too.
I believe you're right.
So this was the last fate to be averted, eh?
Why do you have to still play the animation?
So, yo-me-o.
It looks like your plan for revenge ended in failure.
Yes, and I'm Glad to.
I think I kind of understand now.
What you've been feeling these ten years.
Oh, yeah.
Shanda stood.
She shed tears for me.
That's when my revenge was over.
She saved me from the darkness.
Well, I guess it's time we got back.
A new ten years later was just born.
Oh, what's gonna be different?
Right, we should get back to our new present.
Oh, Missou!
I can't wait to see Miss Lin and Miss Camilla again!
So these past ten years will all vanish.
Will they remember?
Well, not completely.
The memories of all of us here will remain.
Oh!
Wait, what about Camilla and Lin too then?
I love seeing this game.
It's my favorite game after I'm just three or four.
Including the memory of what I did.
My crime.
That's the way this game of the dead works, eh?
And no matter what the reason.
There's no denying the fact that I took Lynn hostage and
tried to point a gun at her.
I have no intention of running away from that either.
The most inexcusable crime in my new life.
Congrats on beating the game in.
Thank you!
Hey, Cicel.
When we go back, our faiths will no longer be
interconnected.
It will be like we never met.
So before that happens, I just wanted to say one thing.
Tonight, I stole away your life with my own hands.
I'm truly sorry.
It's already a thing of the lost past.
have changed now.
Right, Yomiyo?
Thank you, Sissel.
I'm so very glad I met you.
Me too, Yomiyo.
Sissel, are we ever going to see each other again?
I couldn't stand it if we weren't.
Don't worry, Misssel.
I bet we'll see each other again someday.
Ten years from now, our paths are sure to cross.
We'll just have to wait until then.
so I'll never forget you.
I'll never forget you either, Valia, little doggy.
Well, it looks like you've come to live with me now.
So let's be getting home, little black cat.
Home, huh?
That sounds good, Detective Jowd.
We all witnessed the birth of a new beginning.
And now, we're each going back to our own new present.
This is all so weird.
We said goodbye to the parts of our stories that would be
lost.
Believing that someday our paths would all cross again.
Well, I mean, if you have your memories still, you can all
just meet up again, right?
Wait!
Hold it!
Oh, oh, oh.
Before you go back to a new present, I wanted to thank you.
Is this Ray?
Is this the lamp?
Before I cease to exist.
Oh, it's you.
Yes, it is I, Ray, in case you have forgotten again.
Yedi!
Thanks to you.
Everything has turned out as I had hoped.
I'm really grateful to you, Sissel.
Thank you.
But don't forget, I was only on a journey to find my own
lost memory.
Yes, yes, I know that.
Okay.
I know all about you.
Can I ask you a question, Ray?
I want to know.
Who exactly are you?
Fair enough.
I will tell you.
Let me tell you about another version of tonight's events.
Huh?
You changed the fates of many people tonight.
The first of which was hers.
Lynn?
We killed people in the process, too.
We killed other people.
If you had not been there for her tonight, her fate would
have been to die in that lonely spot on the outskirts of
town.
The return of best character of the game.
I thought it occurred.
What do you suppose would have happened?
I don't know.
Let me tell you a story.
The story of a little creature.
What?
After they stole her life that night, they broke into her
apartment.
Oh, Missa!
Don't hurt Missa.
Don't do it.
Oh!
Don't do it!
It's not necessary!
They stole the wooden box from the ceiling, hiding place,
and left.
How did they know it was up there?
And in the process...
They killed them both?
Two little dead bodies were left behind.
What?
However, the little fellow's spirit lived on.
He desperately reached out his paw towards his mistress.
And that's when a miracle occurred.
What?
that the powers of the dead but how she didn't really
understand it himself not yet anyway but with all you know
now i bet you understand it do you not hey wait a minute
look at the toe as he shoots him oh my god why is it oh oh
my god because he was close to sis i mean that yeah sis wait
that's oh my god my brain yum yeah he died inside the aura
of that strange energy.
But unfortunately with his meager powers, he was unable to
save his little mistress.
Oh, there just wasn't anything he could do with only the
power to swap objects.
He needed the power to manipulate objects in order to save
the little lady.
The little fellow chased after the men.
There still wasn't anything he could do.
In the end, he was left behind with the man in red in the
deep, deep sea.
Oh my God, no!
And then, okay, he went back.
He went back to the world the 10 years before to the moment
of the man in Red's death.
Huh?
What?
He decided to wait it out.
He decided to wait until that night came again.
That's the other version of the story of this night.
Is this missile?
He's been waiting this whole time?
Oh my god, Ihajiko!
A story that has taken these 10 years to be retold.
So that was you.
Old soul!
That's right.
I miss...
Hold on, he needs like a really...
What?
No way!
I miss all.
Ten years is a very long time in dark years.
You couldn't change the fates of these people on your own.
Wait, but how did he go back in time?
That's why he had the grandpa voice.
Oh my god, you're right.
So you decided to wait those 10 years out.
Best character.
Meso.
Exactly.
And then at last, that fateful night rolled around again.
Punished old Meso.
Old Mesa.
Oh my god.
But this time I had grown old and my powers were weak.
So I decided I needed to find somebody to help me this time
around.
That's why he lied about the dawn, right?
Just because everything had to be done tonight.
Aww.
Somebody who possessed different powers than me.
But wait a second.
You were able to manipulate that desk lamp.
Over the course of the long years, my powers changed.
My ability to swap objects weakened, but I became able to
manipulate small objects.
But in that case, why didn't you cooperate with yourself?
Because I couldn't.
Ten years and the joint made you an MGS...
I read.
Huh?
From watching the man in red, I found out there were
individual differences in our powers.
I couldn't do any of the things he could do.
Like travel through the telephone lines, for example.
It may not seem like much, but it's very important power.
Especially if you're trying to chase somebody.
Hmm.
But there's something I don't understand.
You knew from the very beginning that I had that power.
How did you know so much about me?
Why wouldn't I?
After all, we had met before on that night the first time
around we what we met before from listening to the
conversation of the two intruders to the apartment I learned
that miss Lynn had lost her life at that junkyard on the
edge of town I followed the ghost world path to the junkyard
and came upon an incredible scene
imagine if you will there in the darkness a twisting and
swiveling desk lamp.
It made my first and on end, I can tell you.
That was me?
So I was shot on that night the first time around as well.
You had lost your memory that time too.
You had just died and you felt confused.
You declined to cooperate.
You declined to cooperate with me.
I did what?
I just want to find my own memory i'm sorry but i can't help
you wait but that happened too that's what you said
whoa and then you disappeared oh a way over the telephone
line
i'm really sorry i didn't help you that's why i decided that
this time i would use that desire of yours to to our mutual
advantage mutual advantage The only thing you were
interested in was finding your own lost memory.
If I could guide you along the right path to doing that, we
would both benefit.
And namely the right path would be the path to the man in
red, to Yomiya.
What?
I gave you the information you needed to know to set you in
the right direction.
And then I gave you a time limit.
A time limit?
That's right.
As you know, I said you only had until tomorrow.
morning.
If I hadn't done that, you wouldn't have found out the truth
tonight.
And the man in red would have been sealed away at the bottom
of the sea forever.
If that had happened, it would have been all over.
Smart doggle.
Then you mean a thing about ceasing to exist?
Oh, that completely made up.
A little naughty of me, I know.
But I just wanted you to use your time wisely.
I really thought that the lamp was the wise.
Oh boy, I hate to admit it, but this little doggy really
outsmarted me in every way.
Let's just call it the wisdom that comes with age.
I didn't expect a missile!
Old missile!
And now it's time to say farewell.
These past ten years will cease to exist and with them, so
will I.
But you'll be regular missile!
You can rest now, old missile!
I believed in you.
I always knew you could do it.
And so you did.
Thank you.
Thank you from the bottom of my heart.
Why do you keep timing it like this?
That's so polite.
It's like a damn poodle.
So you waited and waited these ten long years.
Well, for the sake of your two ladies, Lynn and Camilla, eh?
Of course.
That's because that's what doggies do!
Now then.
Farewell, sisal.
And so the story of a single night came to an end.
A single night that for us spanned across several weeks.
Oh, oh no, I can't even read it!
I made my way back to a new present.
I thought it was pushed to proceed.
I still best boy waited 20 years to help his masters.
Bestest boy ever.
How come it's dark?
This is not push also, so I'll just turn on the lights here.
Oh.
Oh my god.
There's no guns!
There's no gun!
Were you surprised?
You bet I was.
You nearly scared me to death.
Don't joke like that, Lynn.
Yippee!
It worked!
It's not even my birthday today.
It was my mom's birthday the day before yesterday.
I made this surprise for her, but it came out so well, I
want to use it again.
Do we get to see the mom?
That's all right, Lin.
After all, we're celebrating the birth of your new position
as detective, right?
Really?
Thank you, Detective Jowd.
Daddy, you're home.
Hi, Camilla.
Let me introduce you.
This is Lin.
She was just assigned to the Detective Division.
The Detective Division.
The Detective Division today.
It's nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too, and congratulations on becoming a
detective.
Wait, so...
But he should remember this, right?
I guess the two of them don't remember?
Huh?
There's something wrong?
Yeah, one of those badges, too.
Oh, this?
Yeah.
I have one just like it.
My dad gave it to me the other day.
But yours looks a lot older than mine.
How long are you going to keep wearing that toy bag?
badge Lynn oh what's wrong with it to me this is the symbol
of a real detective it's been 10 years since then hasn't it
who would have guessed you'd actually become a detective one
day when he gave me this badge I just knew I knew it was my
destiny somehow destiny hey
and now that I'm a detective I'll find out where that
destiny will lead me So they don't remember, but Yomiya,
Sisul, Missul, and Zhao to remember.
Haha, that you will, that you will.
Yeah, Sisul!
Don't tell me you're the same little kitten.
That's right, the very one.
You know what?
This is a very, very special cat.
He's 10 years old, but he's still a kitten!
Still a kitten.
Yep, he never got any bigger or anything.
Was he... does he have the...
Was he struck with the...
with the fragment?
What a mysterious little fellow.
I know, right?
His name is Sissel.
Sissel.
Seems to me I've heard that name somewhere before.
Really?
How mysterious.
I think Cicil likes you, Lin.
Lin Motomo.
Mom!
Oh my god.
All right, everyone.
Let's start the celebration.
Okay, Mom.
She's so, so cute.
I bet you're just like me.
Your destiny led you here somehow, too.
Meow.
I'm so glad everybody lived.
again, Sissel.
Yay!
From just that single night as a human, I got a glimpse into
their world and I learned something.
Wait, where's Missal?
Where's Missal?
Their fates, their lives, they were all interconnected.
Somewhere, somehow, in some way.
Where's Missal?
And now, this is my new fate.
Oh!
I'm a ghost cat.
Oh my gosh, she...
Look at that spaghetti!
That's the best plate ever!
I guess I really am a cat.
It's just fine to curl up and watch.
Oh, it's too fast.
And it looks like plenty to watch here for quite a while.
Where is Missile?
I was too distracted by the spaghetti to read the text.
Like I said, it isn't my...
birthday oh my god missile hey missile i thought i asked you
to stay home and guard the fort the birthdays are for
celebrating together with friends and loved ones nothing
like it baby oh he's eating the spaghetti the best detective
eats the best meal yeah oh my god look at mataro just
sitting there with her wine
No way Look at this wannabe Look at this You don't even have
half Your pinky toe doesn't even have a fraction of his
smoothness Definitely not good Maybe now I can be a great
detective Just like Inspector Cabanella What kind of example
is the inspector providing for his men?
Such a great game Oh his toes are out Even at the boss Oh,
my goodness gracious.
Here's your food, gentlemen.
She's still looking for someone.
Ew, the toes.
Oh, my God.
Memory, what are you doing here?
I heard you were going to be picking some new members for
the Special Investigation Unit today.
So you took on a part-time job here again just so you could
eavesdrop?
I forgot about this.
I forgot about it again.
Oh, you have no idea the lengths I'd go to reach my goals.
Oh.
Thank you for the awesome playthrough.
I've never cooked this way before.
Tumeric, coriander, cumin, and...
Is this really necessary?
This new curry chicken.
Very best customer requested it.
What about the other country?
I guess they're not interested because there was never...
I don't think I could eat another buy.
So it's who exactly is this very best customer anyway.
Is it missile?
Oh.
Oh, it's this guy.
I really enjoyed your playthrough of Ghost Dricks.
Thank you.
Um.
What was I going to say?
I guess, yeah, the other country doesn't get involved
because...
Oh, here they are doing other activities.
Are you sure we really need...
all these explosives not to worry beauty my dear i follow
the instructions exactly 20 kilograms of gunpowder just like
it said oh my god shaggy is gonna die here i can't wait to
watch it die shaggy die oh wait a minute 20 kilograms i
thought it was 20 grams oh oh lucky day wait does that mean
she also died is this guy also a about to die.
Death to Shaggy!
Aw, but my wife also died.
That's so sad.
So this is where you work, huh, Papa?
Papa!
Why did I say it like that?
That's right, sweetheart.
Darling, husband, don't you have any idea at all you could
give me?
You must have heard some juicy stories.
The indiscretion of a minister?
No, no.
Must you talk that way in front of our darling angel?
Here's to the stodgy mind of my darling husband.
Oh!
So happy I got to watch this game with you.
Thank you!
So awesome!
Ashen, thank you!
Thanks for the spooky numbers!
Ransom beating one of my favorite games of all time.
So good.
I don't think the game needs a sequel.
Hoping that potential sequel alive this deal is going quite
well oh I must say these grapes are quite good the young you
know I was about to scrape the bottom of the sea sir oh oh
god keep it together man are you trying to give me a case of
the vapors I believe I nearly died of fright just now dead
blue lady can be your ghost wife now though ghost
wife oh is this guy Yeah, rock and roll.
Love, peace, and pigeons.
Long live, rock and roll.
Oh, he's going to go check it out.
One of my favorite games ever.
It's so awesome.
I can see why some people say it's their favorite game.
Or one of them.
I love Pigeon Man.
Oh, pigeons joining up.
Pigeons rocking out.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, my God.
Stop the poor for me.
Oh, I didn't get to read it.
Yeah!
They didn't bother changing his prison outfit.
I guess that's fine.
They planned a Ghost Trick 2 where Phoenix Wright dies.
That'd be awesome.
Today's the day, you know.
It's finally getting out.
Oh, he's doing the panic thing.
You know, everybody's starting to get real tired of seeing
you do that.
Now let me show you a new dance that's been passed down in
our family Oh, we do this when we have a stomach ache!
We call it Dance Away the Pain!
Oh, I'm real interested in that one.
I think you could show it to me, say, next week.
You got it!
I love the prison guards.
Bailey, yeah.
This game has such fun character.
Oh, he's getting out!
Ten young long years yo-yo your time's up today the young
lady who always comes to visit you is waiting outside whoop
whoop whoop oh my god wait what was the painting thank you
sisal what's the painting he has working legs I was thinking
that too I was wondering if he like if his legs was oh the
painting oh cute oh my god what a good good babies
is he gonna show up in the picture too Nope.
I always wanted to see you play this game.
It's been such a fun watch.
Thank you, Red.
Thank you.
So cute.
Oh my goodness.
The mom took the photo.
Oh, yeah, I guess that makes sense.
I mean, she wasn't in the game, like, 99% of it, so...
Oh my gosh.
I want to go hug my pets now.
I want to go hug pies and butaro.
I want to go hug them.
I want to especially because Cicel looks so much like pies.
I thought it might take about six hours to beat and we're a
little under that.
So nice.
Thank you for playing my favorite game of all time.
Thank you!
Go hug them.
I will after...
Oh!
Is that a donut?
There it go.
Oh, there's the rat!
Get that rat.
There are so many rats in this game.
Congrats on the completion of one of my faves.
I love how despite all the craziness, everything somehow
gets explained in the end.
best.
Yeah, Missile the best.
Thanks for the pink bikini.
Thanks for such a fun playthrough of such a great game.
Oh, that was so awesome.
Oh my gosh, I'm so glad that I played it.
Oh my god, I'm so glad I played it.
That's so good.
This is good, isn't it?
Oh, Missile.
I can't believe the lamp was Missile all along.
Waiting the 10 years.
That's crazy!
Waiting the 10 years for the whole thing to happen over
again.
Oh my god.
No, it was so good.
Missou's best boy.
Missou.
Look at you, look at the Capcom logo.
Oh, I like the picture of the meteor.
It's so pretty.
This is my first time experiencing this game, doing it
alongside you.
And your voice acting was an absolute treat.
Sorry, my voice acting maybe was a little incandescent.
but it was still fun to do.
Really looking forward, really look forward to them these
past few weeks.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, Cecil background, so cute!
Reincarnation.
I noticed that there was like ghost puzzles.
Like, um, there was like some, oh, the challenges, right?
There was like some other challenges towards the end that
was like, solve...
Oh!
Lead the way outside without failing.
Avert fate without deaths after the final fate change.
So we got one.
Too much medicine.
Take aim and nail it on the second try.
Fail by keeping the ball away from Mino.
We got this one too.
Fail by removing a large symbol.
Clear all challenges.
Complete...
This!
The 5x5 Ghost Puzzle.
What are these?
Ghost puzzle.
Lynn's apartment?
Oh.
No.
Get me out of here.
We'll be here for the next five hours.
He technically waited 20 years.
The cat left him the first time.
That's right.
You're right.
It's a tile puzzle.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Thanks for the great stream, Zvinto!
Thank you!
It's cool though that the puzzle is moving, that's so fun.
Oh wow!
Look at him go!
My brain is actually this, this is, this feels, makes it so
much more difficult.
How am I supposed to know what's in the map?
middle because they're all moving right wait how am i
supposed to know
oh it's oh my god this is so what you like slide puzzles
mint actually i can't say that i'm a fan okay we can see you
know what that's good enough for me
that looks good enough for me We could see a third of it,
you know?
There we go!
Look at that!
It's so yummy!
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you.
What if I do a hint?
Oh!
Okay, it says which one is what?
Ah!
Okay, okay.
Wait, so...
Oh, by five and eight are mixed up.
Oh, well, I think I already knew that actually.
Anyway, okay, I don't want to be here all night because I'm
stupid.
Memories?
All these fun characters.
Oh, beloved mother.
The other me.
Why doesn't the top text change?
But the bottom text changes.
That's weird.
Also, where is Cicil?
Did I just miss him?
Oh gosh, it's...
Who is this?
Oh, that's the Fastidious Glass Polisher.
Black-hearted blue woman.
The change is over the course of the game.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Missile has seven pages.
Friendly little Pomeranian.
His name is Missal, thinking he needs his powers to protect
the little lady he chose not to be brought back to life.
He went back in time 10 years with me to help fight the last
battle against fate.
Me.
The mystery.
I lost my life at a lonely spot in the outskirts of town.
My name is Sisal.
Okay, and then it...
Oh, I see how it changes.
Like, is that me?
Okay.
It's not...
Not me!
Oh, and then he turns into a wisp.
But it doesn't show him as the cat.
It's interesting.
Hmm.
Illustrations.
Oh!
Wait, this is so cool!
Wait.
Missile was almost not a Pomeranian!
Missile was almost a bulldog!
Blue-haired Camilla, blue-haired Camilla, blue-haired
short-haired Camilla, blue-short-haired Camilla,
blue-short-haired Camilla, blue-short-haired Camilla,
blue-short-haired Camilla, come back to me!
Blue-short-haired Camilla!
Oh my god, baby Camilla!
Little baby!
Yeah!
Wait, this one's so awesome!
Actually, they're all awesome!
Whoops, sorry.
The goatee!
oh this one's so cute it's like a like a traditional
detective this one what in the totally spies am i looking at
wow such designs no i i like i like lynn the way she is now
oh this middle one's cute oh my god this middle one is so um
oh my gosh what's her name from uh from Apollo Justice.
Very hard.
It's the goggles.
Funny.
Oh, wow.
She looks so different.
No, I like the design that they went with, though.
Who the hell is this?
Who is this?
Is this the dog?
Water?
Huh?
I like the melon pond in her head.
Who is this?
I was just thinking totally spies.
Who are you?
Who are these people?
Gumshoe?
Ah, Emma Sky, thank you.
I think chat's a little delayed.
Sorry, guys.
Oh my god.
not a thought behind those eyes also looks like in this
picture he's got cow udders
oh my god beaver
camilla again maybe oh these are so fun wow oh my gosh so oh
my god my eyes bright wow oh my god there's storyboarding
for everything wow what is going on here
oh my god that's so cute
oh that's so funny it's what goes on behind the scenes when
the camera stops rolling oh there's even more if i complete
the puzzles okay Okay, maybe I have to complete the puzzles
then.
Wow, thank you for the!
Thank you for the spooky number!
Stellar, stellar!
As a proud black cat owner, I'm glad Cicil got a happy
ending.
Congrats on beating the game, it's been such a wild ride.
Thank you!
I'm really glad I was really worried that I was really
worried I mean I guess we technically lost old missile you
know not everybody made it but old missile also old missile
needed to rest you know so awesome old missile needed to
rest ghost trick oh that's literally what we were listening
to
I like how there's a range and then the origin.
Changing fate.
Yeah!
Did I hear this one?
No.
We'll put on the happy one.
I'm so sleepy!
I think I'm gonna go now guys.
Thank you for watching until the very end.
Thank you for...
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
I hope you guys enjoyed the ride just as much as I did.
And, um, it was so fun.
Oh my gosh, I just realized it's so behind.
Maybe.
I'm gonna go get some rest now, and I suggest you all do the
same as well.
Thank you guys for this fun adventure.
Get some rest.
I'm gonna, actually, I'm gonna finish my dinner, too, even
though it's so late.
I'm gonna finish my dinner.
I'm gonna go get some rest.
Everybody, thank you for letting me play Ghost Trick.
It was so fun.
And, whoa, gosh, I think my head hurts now from crying,
so...
I gotta get some...
Hold on, I have some tea here.
I hope you guys liked it as much as I did.
Gosh, I love stories like this.
Oh, I love time travel.
I love time travel.
Let's see.
Tomorrow, I will be playing Minecraft in the V-Shoujo server
with Henya and Iyer.
mouse so um it will be starting at 8 p.m est sorry again
about no schedule uh up yet um just i i don't know if i'll
be able to do one this week honestly um but uh i'll have one
up next week as well even though it's also a short week
because next week i'll have um be going to off kai so um i
will be there and um yeah uh if you're going to off kai i'll
see you soon my read and um then right after that i'll be
going to japan so um schedule for that when i'm in japan
will also probably be um i'll make a graphic for it that
says like what's going on so you guys don't see like the
same old schedule that's up but um i'll have a schedule for
next week at least at the very least i'm a sucker for time
travel me too me too So, oh, that was very good.
Loved your gameplay and commentary.
Thank you.
Some of the puzzles really did stump me, but I feel I did
all right with some of them as well, so.
Okay, guys.
Get some rest.
I'm going to sleep.
See you, guys.
See you, see you, see you, and I will see you tomorrow,
maybe.
If not tomorrow.
Friday.
If not Friday.
I'm not streaming Saturday.
If not Saturday, Sunday.
Wait, I mean, well, but I'm at the parking lot on Saturday.
If not Sunday, Monday.
If not Monday, Tuesday.
If not Tuesday, Wednesday.
Okay, bye-bye.
Awesome, thank you, everybody.
See you.
Have a good night.
Eat the last time.
Bye-bye.
Oh, my gosh.
I forgot to mention two.
For people that are Patreon people.
i'm gonna be doing a watch along this week as well so i
still am planning here um not sure what time uh i might do
it like sunday sunday afternoon and then stream sunday night
so double neutral that day maybe so yes i'll be watching the
movie together and then then i'll stream something like that
so okay just wanted to say that too because it's just a
little tab all over the place